what's up everybody welcome to the dope
as usual podcast before we get started
this is our pre-roll battery this is
brought to you by us pushtrees.com you
guys been asking for the restock so here
it is homies for life shirt the logo t
no bad vibes we have the whole skate
collection over here and we have the two
pound solid metal ashtray aka a
weapon we got push trees wallets we got
mystery boxes up here
and this section up here is not youtube
friendly so let's move on so just real
quick before the podcast gets started
you guys ask a lot so pushtrees.com for
every single thing you see
quick disclaimer guys we were drinking
before and during the podcast and we
took a break to take some drinks so
we were both kind of [__] up but here
it is guys the goblin episode have a
dope ass day
[Music]
hey what's up everybody i'm thomas
dopazola whatever you want to call me
thank you so much for tuning in to
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast
we're here to talk about life
accomplishments drugs problems and
everything in between
today's episode is going to be a whole
lot of that drugs one all right
today guys the most requested at the
most requested person of all [__]
time we thought eric khan's name was in
the [__] comments a lot
nah you guys dropped do goblin hey
goblin come out you should hit up
i mean i already follow this guy guys
it's here it's finally here the [__]
wait is over goblin what's your what's
your real name man
matt my name is nick nick goblin guys
he's all the way from illinois thank you
for flying out
hey i appreciate you bro thank you for
having me of course i need a good reason
to come out here bro like i didn't want
to just come out here and [__] go
stand in line at dispos the whole time
so that's what she would have done yes
exactly it's still closed but yeah i'm
not fully
at least if the hours were changed you
know that [__] yeah for sure but dude
thank you for being here i appreciate
you for having me guys we started a
little abruptly because we just started
talking for
30 minutes and we're like nah let's
start this we got to film this this is
good [__]
so uh for real quick for everyone else
uh
at home if you're in the car if you're
at home if you don't know who goblin is
can you what do you you know i know what
you say when people ask what you do
what do you say to somebody that already
likes the type of things because you
know when you
meet a parent what do you do oh i do
photography and advertisement when you
meet someone that's
okay oh when i mean a parent i tell them
i sell cars but i mean do you really
yeah dude because i used to i used to
work at a car dealership but um when i
when i tell myself cars
when i never ask no dude because i i
like i got really into the whole like
sales thing at the dealership i worked
at internet sales so like i can talk my
way in and out of any lexus you could
ever name
dude like i i'm very good at pitching
myself to parents but when i meet
someone who doesn't have a problem with
what i do
yeah i just lay it out i'm like yeah you
know i i might have a crack video
you know
i might have a crack video so for
everyone at home
what do you do essentially for the
person in the car that's never
heard of it for the person in the car
that's never heard of it essentially
what i do
is like old school think of like back in
2013 when you hop on youtube and you
watch like a call of duty
player you know they commentate about it
you know they tell they talk about some
hoopla that made no sense i talk about
the game that's boring
i still like to play games and i always
wanted to keep my channel gaming focused
right
so i tell stories about me doing
substances about life
experiences that i've had uh just about
any any sort of like i guess
intoxicating experience in my life and
instead of doing like a vlog or
something like that
i put it over gameplay you know because
i feel like that i still want to keep
the gaming part
like there you know i really want to get
rid of that but when i came across your
channel like a year and a half ish ago
the way i damn damn damn damn they
hey that's urgent the way
the way i put it guys is this is like
story
time over gameplay and the reason is it
got me so intrigued because i went
who is this radio sounding [__]
talking over call of duty and [__]
because the first thing got me
captivated was like yo this fool's voice
just needs to be on the radio
this is what and then i started
listening to stories and go we'd be
friends
i get this yes i like this yes no i
listen i
i'll admit before you you hit me up for
the first time i didn't really watch
much of your content
because like i smoked plenty of weeds so
i was like why don't they watch some
guys smoke weed you know i never really
watched a bunch of youtubers the last
time i watched weedtubers was
back in like when i remember when i was
really young in like middle school
back when like the weed tube scene was
just starting to pop up and like custom
grow it just gotten really big there was
some guy i think his name was like
oh it was red something it's some guy i
just hopped on recently
that bunch a bunch of bunch of like og's
in the community
but since then i haven't really watched
them but then once i uh like once you
hit me up we started kind of getting in
touch
i watch your podcast a little bit and a
bit of your content and then i kind of
started to
to get a little more familiar with your
style and what the weed tube is you know
and i i like it i think it's dope i
appreciate it
i respect it a lot yeah dude i like the
route you took because you
for everyone out there you can't get
paid off weed videos i don't get [__]
paid you can get paid
yeah you can get paid anymore not
anymore but you can get paid because you
show game plan just
you're talking about crazy [__] you're
not actually showing packs and crazy
things
see i you know i i think i've just been
trotting on the thin ice for a little
too long and it finally snapped because
you know i'll say i was disappointed
when i got demonetized but not surprised
when the slide is perfect
honestly i was expecting a termination
email so i mean
hey demonetization i'll take it better
you know
and i mean the better part is it's not
permanent it's just paused
so i mean in 30 days you know i'll read
a nice little oh they told you that yeah
they told
they said that in the email like that
it's paused and it says it on my
dashboard that i can reapply in 30 days
on
july dude i got the date down july 15th
i'm going crazy july 14th
two children storybook readings come on
beat the system bro
because you can't be explicit guys for
everyone at home you can't be explicit
so
the way he's gonna do you just do it so
well you you i like
the loophole yeah keep me on here
i like that it's it's funny dude it's
funny i appreciate it i try really hard
to try
because the thing is like a i don't feel
that either of our content should be
demonetized on youtube i think it's
complete nonsense
that they're willing to put lead content
in recommended feeds
and then on top of that there's still
ads on my videos right now yeah
i just don't get the money same here so
like that's so ridiculous
they themselves don't actually see a
problem with it they just see a problem
with us getting paid
yeah that's their problem it's federally
illegal yeah yeah
it's ridiculous but they'll they'll
break in the check for us oh yeah they
will
just let me keep my [__] yeah and they
don't give a [__] they don't they never
will no
yeah they never will so the way i
like i said the way i found your channel
i saw
multiple videos i was listening to
everything i can see what time are we at
marty
ten minutes oh okay [__] hey
that [__] that's going to be bad words
no we're good okay we're good
to join yourself let's do it dude 10
minute nice guy clock is over guys
you have a you have the ashtray you have
the joint and i never knew it was 10
minutes long
in my videos i would just juke the first
30 seconds
and usually get through them dude listen
i've just been told a lot of things by
like nerd call of duty clickbaiter
friends
and i followed them and half of them are
right and half of them are wrong it's
just yeah that's a toss-up
yeah it's just trial and error yeah so
now we can say [__] and talk about drugs
[__] [__] cocaine you can have a
blast here we go dude you can light that
up whenever you want
you have your stuff right here he's
facing one here yeah oh oh okay
[__] yeah we got rolled up this is
actually my homies have you heard of the
cannabis brothers
they're um two i'm gonna tell a quick
story they're two dudes two brothers
in the 90s they went to prison for weed
right but it's non-violent because
they're
[__] weed dealers exactly right so
honestly every substance dealing offense
should be considered non-violent except
if you're selling like fent or some [__]
yeah but i'm saying like they didn't
have guns they weren't shooting at
people they were in a fight and they got
you know they were just selling weed or
they were just growing weed
so when uh i can't remember what the
prop maybe if you can find on google but
it's a it's an act in california if you
did time in prison
and it was non-violent depending on how
long you went you get your [__] weed
license
so they are legally in the shops now
really yes
and their og is like they just get that
grant like as like a
it's like a it's like i don't know what
it's called
like a california conversation i don't
know what it is dude i can't remember
what it was but
when they got it they're like two like
you know mexican dudes
they're brothers they've been around
forever and now they're in the shops
and this is their really good fire
it's really fun i mean plugging it
without plugging them like legitimately
it's nice i like it i like it a lot nice
yeah dude and they dropped [__] this
week
finally in the store so i'm just smooth
like normally i have a thing where i
smoke because like i'm only a dab guy
i really yeah i do a lot of concentrates
more than flour
but like normally i have a thing where
like i'll cough a [__] lung up after
my first couple of hits of flower but
this shit's smooth dude yeah dude so big
ups to your homies for that yeah
they do a good job man they they
actually give a [__] so uh that's what
we're smoking
so now that's ten minutes guys now we
can really talk about some [__] now we
can have some all right
so i got a bunch of questions i know you
were a drug-filled human
i still am okay you still are and before
we go any further guys we are 100 not
advocating you to do
actually not anymore and also yes 100
uh the content on my channel i feel like
the most important thing for me has
always been to try to share my
experiences but not encourage them you
know
always and like i i have a disclaimer
which obviously we all know like the
disclaimer
no one actually reads that and goes like
oh okay i've changed my mind you know
yes but i feel that i try my hardest in
the way that i explain things to kind of
explain how it is and what it's like
more the intent of giving someone who's
never used it an understanding of the
substance
instead of trying to encourage someone
to do it you know like that's important
to me
uh of course i and i when i end my drug
story times ago
and this is the story of why you
shouldn't do this
it goes downhill don't do drugs like
[__] you yeah so
before we start guys because this is a
this is a drug-filled conversation this
is yeah
this is about to be drugs oh this is
gonna be a fun one [__] wait
um so let me get straight into this here
we go
if you uh i have my little uh notes over
here
you said you started making videos uh
call of duty what you used to do
so all right i've i've been making
youtube videos technically since i was
in like eighth grade
i was it was like 2012. me and my
friends you made this call of duty clan
together
and we made a youtube channel for it and
i went on there and i bought this like
little capture card for my xbox
and i was the only one who had one so i
had to record and upload like all of our
gameplay you know
and it was like 360p god-awful quality
and i was the only one who had a laptop
with like a built-in mic so i'd talk
over it
you know so i'd just be like oh hey hey
here's our gameplay
watch us [__] [__] on these kids you
know like you know just just
some random [__] cod gameplay and as
time progressed
i um i think the first substance related
video i ever uploaded was in like 2015 i
want to say
uh towards the end of the year i uh
like honestly i was running out of video
ideas i didn't really know what to do
and i also was i was like because of how
young i was i was like oh if i tell
people i smoked weed before or something
i'll get in trouble you know yeah
illegal state yeah yeah exactly and also
being a minor being the age i was i was
like oh i can't talk about that
but then you know i i uploaded the video
anyways and i was like you know i'm just
going to tell the story i'm going to
share my experience
and it got more views than like anything
i'd ever posted on my channel and i was
like [__]
dude this is the formula you know like
this is it i gotta keep doing this
like if it ain't broke don't fix it so i
just kind of kind of worked from there
and you know
i feel that the formula for my content
hasn't really changed much
in the past four years like youtube wise
it's it's literally if you go watch a
video of me from 2016
same thing as today it's just gameplay
and commentary yeah yeah
that's important to me it's like and
you're just sharing your life
yeah it's not like you're sitting there
gaming all day you have to go live
and oh man i know i try to i try
for everyone out there i try to like
baby these joints because i
when i'm having a conversation it's hard
to
dude i took it one dab this morning
before my flight and that's it
oh yeah i have not smoked for the past
like eight to ten hours so yes
spectacular yeah i try to i try to like
i i guess you could say i waste the
joint when i talk but
it doesn't occasionally it's for
ambiance and smell there's enough wheat
around
exactly we'll make it we'll survive
we'll survive but it's hard to have a
full conversation not trying to cough in
the mic yes okay i tried it i tried it
but um so i want to know
when's the first time you ever did drugs
man any any kind of drugs whatsoever
because i know you know do you count
weed and alcohol i can't weed and
alcohol
pardon me all right interesting i
personally i don't count weed
i don't think we is a drug no no not
like wheat is drug but
put this away but okay yeah like for
this question you get in trouble
yeah yeah of course okay so i got drunk
before i ever smoked weed actually
it was my uh it was my okay in freshman
year i didn't go it's my sophomore year
homecoming
and i uh there's like a like a school
friend of mine that i had named bob
who he's a he's a comment i've mentioned
he's really he's been in a few of my
videos i got invited over to my house
and got just
[__] wasted and recorded a few videos
and
um he but he asked me to take him down
because of his employer he was like he
hit me up and he was like dude if they
google search me like
what if they find me and i kept trying
to explain to him like dude i didn't put
your whole name in the video like
they're not gonna find you but he was
super drunk and like i wanted to respect
him so i took him down
yeah you know um
but i'm [__] stunned but what's the
question again honestly
that's the first you said you're a
homecoming 10th grader
shout out to whoever's [__] weed this
is dude
this shit's great um nah yeah so my
first time getting getting
[__] up ever um
i saw the genuine [__] i know dude i
blinked out i was like
i do every [__] podcast what the [__]
are we talking about but no
oh my god so no it was it was 10th grade
homecoming
i went to this girl named daniella's
house she invites me over and at the
time like you know she was kind of
attractive you know i was kind of
into her so i was like you know i'm
going over to her house
so i go over with a buddy of mine named
jason we walk over the house my other
friend
adrian we all walk over to her house
after homecoming she lived like two
blocks away from her high school she was
no biggie
so we walk over to her house we go
outside and her parents are home
but they're upstairs and they're okay
with the party for some reason
downstairs is a bar the parents just
like
expect us to not be drinking and
danielle or daniella i don't remember
the girl's name dude i've talked in like
five years dude
um one of the two pardon me
she goes downstairs and just starts
pouring out shots for people
and at this point i'd never drank i've
never done any of that [__]
but oh [__] my friend adrian he'd never
drank either and he was just
he was out of pocket all the time she
was like yo dude let's take a shot like
let's
let's [__] do it and i was like all
right you know i'll try it were you
super straight edge until this moment i
wouldn't say straight edge it's just i
never really hung out with the people
who would present me the opportunity
got you like i i hung out with people
who would play video games you'd ride
the walgreens and [__]
get snacks and then we'd go go he's have
to play games innocent children
you're an innocent child yeah i wasn't a
bad kid i just wouldn't do my homework
you know oh yeah that was me yeah
exactly like i did
i really caused you to chaos i didn't
like break [__] do all that [__]
i just [__] chilled you know i just
played games and then one day
i got drunk at the homecoming party and
i remember
we uh we took our first shot off this
counter
she gives us she pulls out like her
parents had such a nice house
beautiful like i grew up in a pretty
nice area right
um i imagine so if you're not
do you grow up in like a ferris bueller
neighborhood no no no no no no no no
i imagine all right everybody i lived in
a town house
like i didn't i didn't live in like a
like an actual like standalone house
but within like walking distance of my
neighborhood was like beautiful
beautiful houses and like they had a
clubhouse and everything like like crazy
[__] right oh
[__] so you could walk over there and
just like go to the pool and go to the
tennis court like it was crazy
oh it's nice like rich people [__] even
though you're not a part of the
neighborhood they don't know because
like i just walk over there with my
buddy jason who was right yeah let's get
in that [__]
but um oh
i got to get you're ripped
god damn
dude you showed me that bong i forgot
and i my heart skipped a beat i was like
bro we gotta [__] rip that [__] sure
six foot yeah yeah we've established in
six four hundred percent
six four six four he's taller than this
[__] five seven
dude that's [__]
i'm not a tall man i am a short man but
that's all right you know
there's nothing wrong with that in my
opinion i'm chilling i forgot what the
[__] i was you talking about it's okay
bro you're
welcome welcome okay you got drunk as
[__]
do your shots bro
i mean i came here drunk actually i got
a bottle of room service
oh nice uh they had a they had this [__]
called turtle rock or whatever it was
like some rose i don't [__] know
but i just drank the bottle of it oh god
no it was actually good dude it was like
no not the fact that you drank the drink
the bottle of it bro oh
no i'm no bro i'm an alcoholic dude you
don't have to worry about it
have you ever seen one of my live
streams i saw you drinking some beers
the other night
looking like a [__] all-american
with your [__] cut off shirts and
[__] right is this right
i don't know what the [__] i just i took
a fat ass dab
and i was really stoned and i just got
the idea to dress up like a like a super
southern country that's what you looked
like
i know you're like a bro dude i bought i
went to walmart
i bought a ford hat and like these like
reflective glasses
softball it's like a budweiser tank top
cut off
yes yes perfect well he looked like he
was about to call me a [__]
yes that's the way he looked i was like
i looked racist
[Laughter]
you look at you automatically it's funny
you wake up with a beer no 100 i drank a
lot of natty light that stream
and some guy came in my chat and told me
to buy american truck simulator and play
it what does that mean
it's it's a game on on uh on oh god you
got you so
obviously i obliged i was like that's
the best idea i've ever been
like that's the best idea i've ever
heard bro like i'm dressed like a
country man
and this guy wants me to play a trucking
game like that's perfect [__] perfect
and it's 20 bucks i'm buying that game
right now
you know so i bought that [__] and then
i was i was so wasted by the time that i
played it
that i just kept crashing the truck and
i had to quit the game
i couldn't play the game anymore dude
i i uh the only reason i i used to drink
i don't i know
for watching the videos i just drink a
lot but i could drink like a smoke it's
just
maybe because you're like built like me
yeah you could just [__] shrink
can you drink a fifth and be okay yes
same but that won't be done
yeah it won't be blacked out yeah i'll
be [__] up the fifth of what though
what's your drinking
hennessy yeah really i'm gonna say
i don't like hannah's no i don't think
anybody really likes hennessy i just
like it more you drink it straight yeah
i chase a little
water after really yeah oh
no dude i it's you're gonna last for me
jaeger or
buzz yo dear the [__] smashes a
ball over his head in a bar
dude all right [__] yo you want to hear
some crazy [__]
i used to drink so in 2000 you know only
use me blade
what did you just say do you know who
only use me blade is he's like a call of
duty content creator i don't play games
bro
do you no but i'm about to pull his ass
up though i don't play games oh
you're gonna find some [__] up [__]
only oh no
no spaces only use me blades
so in 2018 i went to this event called
pax and this guy pissed on the couch
when he was asleep he was so drunk
but his turn his channel got terminated
he's really cool he was so [__] up
that he pissed on the couch
so what was the gaming tournament yeah
yeah so it was packed uh one of the pax
events have you ever seen those
bro all right all right i played i
played i'm gonna fill you in madden and
in in january bro how was it
why don't you play more video games i
got time bro when i stopped playing
games i started editing that's
that's when i mean that's the grind
that's i respect that yeah i just i
i'm not addicted to that [__] so if i
play one game and go oh you beat me by
three [__] girl
16 games [__] like i can't i can't
play madden like that dude no
i like the maddens when i was a kid but
i feel like you were cooler
yeah yeah now they're just like so
realistic it's like i watched the ncaa
games dude
did you play uh nba jam
what was that was the football one oh
you're telling me nba street
are you talking about blitz no there was
a [__] football one
of nba jam or no no no hold on hold on
there was like some crazy ass [__]
and yeah oh
i'm so that's what i said nfl street
[__] i'm talking
no oh my god that's what i said did you
say that yeah you said nba street
yeah yeah no you didn't maybe i swear to
god he did not say nfl
i remember part three part three was
wild would you keep the
keep the this was one of the best video
games ever made
on the wall wall ride keep the points
going
you could juke people off the wall yes
nfl street was the [__] that was my
summer of 12 years old i
[__] loved nfl street i was way
younger
how old are you by the way i am you're
i'm 31. i'm about to be 32 yeah wow
well i did not know that i know i always
like i look like a little kid you dude
you look like you look like you're
around my age i know people always
like i [__] forget man i forget often
dude oh [__]
what [__] i just forget bro
time goes by so fast i'm doing i'm so
busy all the day i started this when i
was 23.
yeah that's when i started doing videos
and or doing pictures and [__] so
five years went by fast as [__] and then
i've been here for five years so that's
exactly
what did you do before you were doing
videos and all that like selling packs
that's all i ever did bro nice i mean i
can legally say it now
because of age i was selling pack [__]
that i was selling packs
while i started instagram like when i
started doing all that stuff
i stopped like seven eight months in
because i realized like no bro this is
not the way because i'm a small town
you're getting raided yeah you it's
never yeah yeah yes it's like 100
percent
yeah it's all i ever did man it's a lot
of you sell weeds i was a kid
that's how i play let's pay for
everything holy [__] dude a joint
it's honestly so you're the only guest
ever to be ripping the [__] out of the
joint though
i mean i mean yeah yeah basically think
about it i mean
people smoke weed but no one's here
doing [__] hitting what do you mean
i see you normal
for weed smokers every day weed smokers
they get [__] up like us
well yeah but normal everything the
thing is if you don't smoke don't eat
every day you don't smoke weed
well this is a difference people can
smoke wheat every day smoke a joint
right cool yeah but like us like oh a
joint
do you want to smoke another one after
what the [__] for one joint
that's how i feel people like us
absolutely yeah it's like
that's how i process everything yeah
like i'm like dude we should [__]
smoke some crazy [__]
like that's how i always think yeah so
you're ready to chill oh yeah
dude what i i came prepared dude
i sat in my room and i ordered room
service i called them and i said give me
a [__] bottle of rose
and i went out to the balcony and i
drank the entire thing and i called an
uber driver
and i [__] came here [__] break
the tank
but that's cool but oh that's what we're
talking about drinking fifths
yeah i just i i always have to drive
that's why i don't drink a lot i
always i feel that and i have stuff to
do i feel that
dude i just got my license back a few
months ago i got it
do you want to talk about it all right
i already got sentence for it all i'm
gonna say is i
i i made a grave mistake i did get a dui
i [__] up i got sentenced for it
doing my community service all that i'm
not too bad for like
another year but like it's i already got
sentence for it like it's already dealt
with
i'm already dealing with it you know
[__]
wow that's that's not i mean
before you were 21
oh how [__] yeah that's
even way worse i feel like right on your
insurance yeah
my insurance is like 300 a month bro
that's [__] amazing
dope you dude no you don't even know
like my shirt's so high bro how many
cars have you crashed
none she said it was a nice car it's
that we live in l.a
my insurance is so unbelievably high it
made me go
do i want this [__] car because
that's real life [__]
bro three minutes a month is amazing
that's [__] i mean
but then again you're in another state
we're in [__] l.a
you know what i mean alicia i don't
drive like a new car
oh oh that's 300 on top of that i have a
i have a 2003
mercedes uh c-32 amg
no can you bring that [__] up the [__]
out of gear richard
can you bring that up on my instagram go
to my instagram it's interesting
[Music]
scroll down a little bit oh there's some
pictures of me dude
scroll down a little more there's there
it is
there's bro that's a 2003 yeah that does
not look like i know
that's what i'm saying that's nice it's
clean
that's what i'm saying yeah [__]
415 horsepower dino i don't know about
cars bro
oh that's pretty nasty i mean that's
like for that year of a car that's
pretty good bro
yo that's a whole the guy gave me the
paperwork for that [__]
dude i i love that thing dude like the
interior
than that no okay so i yeah i could see
why
the [__] i'd take good care of that
thing nice i know i didn't
i'd never even be like that yeah 300
about this is
but if you're in another state i get
whites i got i got geico
damn right i switch all the time whoever
gives me a better deal on [__]
i mean yeah dude the the old company i
was with dude geico actually gave me the
best deal
good which is so they're real the
commercials are dude i couldn't
i because the thing is if you call the
insurance company and you really like
get on their ass about it bro
get on the what what do you mean listen
give me the tips
tell me tell me can you sell cars what
do we got to do whatever
all right all right all right all right
i don't sell cars anymore
i know but you know the knowledge of how
to talk you're good the knowledge of how
to talk to fools
what am i gonna do what do you mean you
get on their ass all they do is tell me
a quote and i go no or yes
there's more you could do what do you
mean
please put the only two things that have
ever come to your mind when they ask
that is no or yes
why would they give me a lower deal if
they could they would do it
you call them yo and you say like
you get a quote from a different company
that's slower i have like five don't
okay so you present them to the company
that you actually want
oh i don't care who it is as long as i
have full coverage and all my shit's
ready to go
i mean i don't know dude
that shit's important that shit's
important well i only stick with
progressive
geico allstate geico's good guy feels
good i switch between those three like
every comment all state's nice whoever
will give me a lower deal bro i don't
know bro progressive is whatever
i i don't know man you
that's what i'm saying you tell me
because i i just so when i was a when i
was young before i moved on my mom's
house
i worked at a lexus dealership for like
it wasn't that long it was like [__]
maybe like eight months
right but i started off as like a
receptionist
and then they sent me back as a cashier
in like the afternoons and then
eventually they put me in service
so like i started like learning a little
more about the cars
and then i started like helping out with
the internet sales dudes when they'd
show up like when new clients would show
up and
[__] because i was a receptionist right
like they'd have me like
come help push the car on them you know
like be like oh look at this here's the
features all that [__]
because i'm just saying well man because
i'm listening to you talk now
trying to convince somebody [__] i
had to talk so much about the lexus rx3
350 bro we made bands on those
i because the thing is i worked as a
cashier
and then eventually like i helped with
sales so like as a cashier they made me
do the ledger in like all the books
so i saw how much like they sold and how
much they paid for him
dude gotcha they made a
[__] bank how much is the commission
on a car that car
it depends on the sales person like
right now you
if you were still selling cars what's a
typical commercial i mean
okay the thing is i never really got
commissioned on selling a car i would
just help people like sell them was they
wouldn't really
they'd [__] me their commission oh god
it depends on the sale price above like
retail
the r350s they paid something honestly
around like
[__] 55 for them it's something for
like
the branding model like way above that
if i remember correctly i don't know i'm
[__] stoned
[Laughter]
i have no idea dude i had worked there
like four years ago
i got you potentially because i want to
know because when i went i tried to get
a new car
and the guy sitting there with me goes
who sold you this [__] car
like that i'm gonna go to mckinley i'll
put on blast temecula mercedes
he goes where's this 16 000
where is this floating i go you tell me
goes no
why is there 16 bands extra
over your in taxes and fees
well i don't know he goes
damn i feel really bad for you man they
got you let's get straight
they got you so i paid so much more over
the [__] what i should have
and i have no idea so i don't know cars
i need to bring my cousin next time i go
like yo you you talk to him dude
because i don't know i don't know next
time i'm in la i'm gonna take a vacation
out here in august
with my girl right now i planned it in
august yes that's when i want to get the
car
dude it's perfect it's going to be okay
somebody else is meant to be
i don't know cars i'll come with you
listen i'm aggressive don't
like like i'm aggressive with it like
before go for it a salesperson
the sales person he says marty i know i
said i might i said i might
no i love it either way it's okay
yo that's a shirt on the first one
i'm aggressive that's what i need
because i'll be the thing is oh that's
how much you'll do you got to know how
they work and like
i don't though that that's why i need
like okay i'm going to put this out this
is pretty much right yeah
i'm [__] big that's some great weed
dude that's some phenomenal yeah
it's good that's so fire honestly
wow so that's some good [__] i don't
remember where the [__] we were at
oh they're honest what the [__] are we
talking about it's time for a fan
question
every time i forget what the [__] i'm
talking about okay we bring up a fan
question all right let's do it
so i asked people goblins coming on the
show
drop some questions these are from
patreon
this is from bernardo from patreon does
your family know about all the stuff you
do
my mom does i don't really know about my
dad's side because i don't really talk
to any of them
so my same town no my parents are
divorced and they have been since i was
super young
so my dad i haven't talked to him since
like i was probably like
i'd say 17. oh [__] so it's been a
minute yeah it's been a
dead suck yeah he's not he's he's not
the best
dude so uh i chilled with my mom
for a long you know a while longer until
i got kicked out of her house
you know for for what my dui
kidding me she she kicked you out
because of that
she was like get the [__] out of my
house are you [__] serious yeah
is she straight-edged completely
religious or something no she's not
really religious
i've smoked weed with her what's the
pros problem
i don't know do you i mean i've gotten
drunk with her like 100
like a bunch of times hey mom i made a
mistake like
the [__] out of my mind dude yeah she
the date so she came to pick me up from
jail
right when i got bailed out she came to
pick me up
and she told me as soon as i got in the
car she's like get your [__] together
you got a week to get out of my house so
i had to call my friend and that's how i
ended up in that shitty old house i was
talking about earlier
before we started before we even started
recording telling oh boy
okay so i paid i lived at this house
where the rent was 650 a month and i had
two roommates
there was two bedrooms actually
downstairs
the bathroom was in between them there
was no heat
we moved in to the house in october so
you can imagine how the no heat there's
no snow there
yeah bro it's illinois southern illinois
i know so remember earlier we're talking
about like i was hot as [__] oh
so all right it it tweaks dude in the
winter
it snows bad in the summer i
like you get the worst of both it's hot
as [__] in the summer
it's a lot of [__] [__] in the way it's
yeah it's [__] it's [__]
so keep going you had the 650 house no
see
the 650 house no he we lived down there
we were [__] blown we like
literally my two roommates downstairs
they only lived there for a month
right they eventually moved out because
like one of them like
all right so my friend his older brother
one of my roommates my friend cody
uh his older brother was going to jail
so he asked my other roommate josh
for a ride home as he's going to jail
like a few days before okay so josh
gives cody a ride
like three hours you know four hours no
it was a long ass drive because they
they [__] it dude a mission give me a
ride
across the country he literally said
like yeah drive me like
like [__] four or five hours north
dude and he was just like okay so he
grabbed all his stuff
the thing is i didn't realize he grabbed
all his stuff because he
he didn't have much all he had was a
playstation 4
a couple games and like a couple you
know piece of clothing
so you just threw him all his car took
my other roommate and
left never came back oh [__]
right he dropped off my homie at uh
at his like his older brother's house
right so he could like see him before he
went to jail
then he left while my friend was asleep
after telling him he's gonna spend the
night
and he blocked us both on snapchat and
just never spoke to us again
what the [__] yeah yeah what the [__]
yeah so i had to this day bro yeah so i
had no
car at this point because he took the
only working car and just
laughed it's like the middle of the
night cowboy [__] when they sneak off
with the horses
dude he snuck off with the horse i
couldn't believe i had no car
and the only food we had in the fridge
was like
pizza hut so i mean bad times
but then i uh i moved into a different
house
so that was and then you know i just
moved to a different house so the 650 is
when you got kicked out of your mom's
you moved in that house yes that that
was a nightmare house dude so i lived
upstairs in the loft because there was
the two bedroom right
sounds like it's like a terrible place i
don't know why it wasn't that bad but
just the way you're describing it all
right this case up
was made out of like plywood so it was
kind of sketchy
okay i get it i mean you get the price
dude and also the stove didn't work
so you're cooking on a hot plate you
said oh yeah yeah we're talking about oh
we we take a hot plate and we go into
like the loft or like one of my friend's
bedrooms and we like throw some eggs on
that [__] or like some [__]
bacon cooking like [__] we just
smoked something
we just smoked some blunts and just
cooked some eggs and bacon on that [__]
and that's all we'd eat
dude that's all we need i imagine whip
it's on the ground for some reason
no it sounds like some [__] from kids
you ever seen the movie kids
here's i i have i actually haven't it's
[__] good i don't know why i haven't
i'll text it to you after you leave so
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what it's actually it sounds like some
just some
please text it to me 18 19 year olds
like yo we're broke but we just have
enough money for rent we'll get food
every day
that's what it feels like no that's what
it was there was this one gas station we
went to
it was called oh it was like it wasn't
even on maps we just drove
past it one day that's how you know it's
bad right
so it was still not mad
to this day it's not on man so i don't
think the world don't acknowledge them
we drove past it oh my god i don't it
was like the murder shop
is what it was called we pulled up one
day because they don't id and they sell
cigarettes for 50 cents a pop
oh it's one of those spots yeah yeah we
had like five bucks
so we sent my friend cody in then he
walked in they asked where he was from
and this isn't the what what town is
this oh
man i don't know if i want to just close
down on the podcast oh oh yeah
yeah for sure but it's in it's not in
your hometown anymore it's not my
hometown that's what i should ask
yes so you're not in your mom the town
where you live in dubai yeah it's not my
hometown
gotcha but um no
so we go into this store that it's not
this is literally not on maps like i
googled it
there's like no there's no such thing
dude like i don't know what this place
is i don't know how to review it you can
buy singles
yeah you can go into my single
cigarettes like marv reds for like 50
cents
so like it's crazy dude they're making
so much money
ten bucks a pack that's some high school
[__] my friend spence was in the
cigarette nazi
at some high school [__] that's some
that's some [__] i do when i was like
16. my home used to
[Music]
it's decent dude i mean it's just like
trapping but you're not doing really
anything that bad
yeah oh my god
you look high as [__] i'm [__] stoned
dude i didn't smoke all day i know i
could see it in your face you just
i just took one dab this morning and i
said all right this is it
i watch i try to go to the airport bar
do my uber driver
this is a dramatic pause roll my uber
driver
no i swear to god dude my uber driver
i'd rather have my grandmother dude
she's senile
i really messed it up senile ridden
bro you don't even know you know i swear
to god okay
was a guy or a girl driving a girl old
woman
she picks me up and she's like can we go
to the gas station
on the other side of town they have gas
for 287 a gallon that was
[__] big i was [__] up i i
consumed some substances i was ready to
go
i was a little coked up i was excited i
was like
yeah you know do whatever the [__] you
want
you know yeah go to the gas station i
don't care if i'm [__] late
yeah i was like just go to the game i
almost was she was like oh we might not
get there until like three o'clock and i
was like
i leave at 3 30. like how am i
like like like trying to save a couple
cents a gallon and
off she didn't do that before like what
the [__] is wrong like
like that's so that like that wasn't
right that's rude
that wasn't right at all so i was i was
so
blown and i mean not at the time
i was that blown but then i started like
you know as i was sitting in the car i
went in the gas station you know while
she was like she was like filling up her
car with gas or
or whatever i got like two two waters
you know i came back to the car
got in the back seat and she goes in the
gas station after she's done filling up
and like waits in line to buy some [__]
and it takes like 15 like
the line's the longest the line's dead
ass
so long like i'm sitting there and i'm
like
in disbelief you're in the car uh yeah
i'm standing in the back seat of her car
alone now that's a guest she starts
squeegeeing the windshield she's
vacuuming dude
i was sitting there and i was like man
what if i just take this vehicle right
now i was thinking the same time
yeah me too i was like wow this this
would be a fun time but i
i didn't do i would wow this would be a
fun time as you
ponder stealing a car i [__] love
you
[Laughter]
i mean
i've seen all of my head you steal it
and you're still late to the airport
[Music]
is probably the worst airport i've ever
been to
really why it's just [__]
it's so shame
i thought small towns are good airports
right no say
st louis is not a stable town
yeah the biggest city that's a big city
um oh my god your
[__] face and everybody's driving
right now
just this i'm sitting in the back seat
of this woman's car
and she's like she gets behind a truck
on purpose as the lane's ending
like a mile and a half ahead and i'm
like oh you should maybe get around this
truck and she's like
we'll be there around three o'clock and
uh yeah
like like a big like semi like yeah
a truck that's causing problems and i
was like get the [__] around
it you know like please like i was
trying to be nice because you know she
was a nice old lady but like
i was scared i was gonna miss my flight
and
eventually she went around it
and she got scared and she like pulled
back behind it
because the truck like so all right
lanes are ending
the truck was kind of cutting up with
the middle right
she like waited a while and i was
telling her i was like you should really
go around the truck and she's like are
you sure
the lanes are how old was she
was she old enough to be someone's
grandmother she old enough to be a
goddamn uber driver
like too old potential
grandmother range i didn't really ask
many ques yeah i'd say grandma
yeah okay yeah she was at least the fact
that you're coaching her and she's like
do you think she makes me furious you
know i was telling you why are you doing
this job [__]
she was telling me about her son that
did drugs for some reason she was like
getting real personal when i was like i
don't really like what's she buying this
door
that's a big question what'd she come
out with do you remember
because if it was a cigs and a pepsi it
wasn't lazy it wasn't safe but she got a
water i think
it was like uh but it was a [__] water
like it was like a
like a dasani or some [__]
yeah i just don't know she almost backed
over like a young child
yo wait when she was leaving the parking
lot bro
listen to all these [__] these things
coming together now
yeah you know did some substances you
[__] go to the gas station
she [__] i'm coming down from coke
and she's
[__] she gets in the car and she
literally throws it in reverse and
there's these kids walking past the car
this one girl's like right up by the
trunk and she [__] backs up and the
kid screams
he's like oh [__] she got so close to
him the kid like slapped the car
right like so close bro literally i look
back and i was like oh my god like what
like
like you know like what the hell are you
doing this is prior to the truck
she goes this is prior to the truck
she goes oh no problem
[Music]
you know that that that kid got too
close to the car
like a [__] through the diversion don't
worry i'm not mad you got too close
yo all this happened to you today bro
this
yeah was the flight okay
there's i mean i all right you sound
like me
i mean listen i brought i brought some
goodies with me on the
on the let's not disclose it's not just
oh and the uber is different
i thought you talked about the airplane
i said how was the airplane ride
was the fight okay at least yeah it was
just okay it was [__] up
is you to drink anything on the plate no
i didn't drink anything
oh no they didn't let you drink on the
plane well i mean drink like
alcohol yeah no oh no i have to drink on
the plane bro
no i took
things that wouldn't allow me to drink
oh okay gotcha
jesus christ all this is happening in
one day
that's amazing i mean all these
instances
all these things the kid almost getting
hit by the car the
whole [__] lady is stopping talking
about one drive into the airport
one drive to the airport is this a movie
i don't know
it's a movie scene all this i love it
not really dude
no no i was just trying to get to the
end i know but i don't know
you got to think about it in the terms
of it's not you
ready in terms of it's not you you just
told that story to someone
okay me and i'm thinking of myself
watching this happen going there's about
20 times i think i like explode
and just start [__] screaming because
the character the driver the driver in
itself the driver
[__] and then you're coming down 30
minutes later like can you go around the
[__] truck what do you do
maybe i shouldn't let you [__] ass stop
for some [__] gas like i could see it
all
working i could see it i was so mad at
her dude
like i wanted to get to the airport you
ever seen goodfellas
you know the scene uh the day he gets
busted by the dea i think it is yeah
and he wakes up [__] helicopter
remember and he goes and he's like i got
this guns i gotta drop these guns and
the tommy's
sorry what are you saying stir the sauce
so does it stick i'm stirring i'm
stirring
and he's like all right these guns don't
even fit i could tell he didn't like it
because he didn't even say goodbye when
he closed
that's this morning
damn that's a good movie that's your
life right now to me
that's how i'm imagining all this so
it's like a movie i don't know i mean
i know it's just you walking the store i
mean go to the store but like with me
when people tell me the same [__] i'm
like for all i do is do a bunch of lines
with my friends like we did a lot
that's one of the times i remember but
it was like
moving but i was just getting and then
you think about it you gotta
when you do you ever film yourself
talked about these stories um
in the sense of like you know film your
actual body your actual face talking
sometimes
on stream i'll do like a live story
that's about it okay
do you ever watch it back sometimes
sometimes
that's because you're that's the reason
why i started following your [__] i'm
like oh this is a good storyteller
i like this that's why i like it so
when i'm hearing you talk it's like okay
i can see where this is going
and 100 i'm saying like you you should
think about that i know you do a lot of
gameplay too but the streaming maybe
like
set your [__] up to like portrait mode
and get [__] up and like crazy
i do oh okay okay okay i didn't catch
those so i got sometimes
on i used to on youtube not anymore
obviously because of what's going on and
also because
i get that on my twitch a little bit you
know do it on twitch bro
twitches these are [__] entertaining
man the thing is like i'll take like a
bottle of jaeger
and just [__] slam the [__] out of it
with some red bull
like some shoe nice type [__] you're
getting [__] up
nice like i'll just like pour yak mom's
like really rough oh i thought you meant
you were gonna chug the box
no no no no no no no
no no that's not too bad no
that's not what i meant at all that's
not what i meant at all but like
i'll i'll get through a bottle pretty
quick like realistically
if i finish let's say three quarters of
a fifth
i'll probably pass out and be functional
the next day yeah
if i finish a whole bottle i might
puke a little bit but that's just part
of life
like you know and jager bro yeah like
yeah
like if you don't vomit at some point in
your life and you're consuming
you know some sort of intoxicating
substance
have you done it you know enough or
properly
i feel you definitely not i feel you so
let's
let's roll that into something since we
could talk about this
and once again guys we're not trying to
say you should go do drugs and
whatsoever youtube i don't think we're
trying to tell you go do drugs this is
experiences
when you first start no not when did you
first do coat what's that
not that it's when did you first find a
friend named cocaine
because that [__] was tight and
like i said i'm not trying to advocate
it
i'm just saying for me it's like my
[__] homie
dude i i loved it but it's death to me
that's why i can't [__] with it
i agree with you i can't i cannot do
enough of this [__] [__] stop stop
stop yo we can't we can't we can't
that's too it's i feel like all right
everybody out there that don't
don't
oh okay all right yeah yeah like like
five day bender's
type crack but no no i'm talking about
like i used to love
coke i have a deviated symptom i just
went to the doctor
my nose is i i refuse to go to the
doctor because i don't i don't want to
know
because i just gets [__] science
infections
obviously you know jokingly i still do
it you know
obviously jokingly i still you
[__]
yo so i i used to do coke
because i loved it because it was the
[__] except it's like
oh you could die i'm willing to gamble
no [__] that [__]
that's why i stopped but the only reason
the only reason me personally
i have friends that do that [__] in
front of me and go dad she looks [__]
bomb
dude but i won't do it because i know i
can't
like i can't do that [__] i stopped last
time i did it i was like
seven years ago eight wow yeah it's been
a long time
i don't think there's ever going to be a
point in my life where it's been that
long
since i've done it i think there will be
when you start
getting so busy that it's like
ah this is gonna hurt my body i'm not
telling i'm not this is not way like
do what you're gonna do if you like
drugs do drugs but for me
it's it's so like with everybody [__]
up and like oh he it was fentanyl oh it
was cut with this i
hate my number one worst thing and all i
will say
is um obviously
you know jokingly the stuff that i get
is really good
and consistent
so it's like there's no cameras here
that's the [__] that i'm getting is
really good i know i totally understand
like
the coke my friends do and they get i
see it come off a brick i
see it yeah and like i get it like oh my
gosh
yeah can i take a bite of it yes yes but
i don't do drugs no more and then
me going see nope i'm going to smoke
weed
my life but the thing is you're 22 years
old
i get it i'm not saying like you're
young dude i'm saying it's your life do
what you're gonna do and the thing is
you know i
i try to share my experience in a way
where like
it's not a good thing like no we all
know it's nothing because
the amount of like problems that it
causes
especially long term are never worth
what you get
from and at the end of the night i
always feel like [__]
yeah i know i always like i always have
like clean out my nose and like try to
fall asleep and no amount of weed will
fix it
you know it sucks oh i hate that feeling
so
you know yeah it's terrible sitting up
with just
bored to [__] yeah tweaking you can't
even go we can't even watch something
funny because off your i want to do more
drugs then
rocker [__] hate that off your
[__]
[__] oh god i brought back so many men
no oh
don't even oh i i got i get what you're
saying bro
it's just i just can't do it man that's
all
i mean i look i loved it if the doctor
was like yo
you're so healthy a pound of cocaine
would kill you i would go
maybe i might do all right but i know i
wouldn't because
i love coke so much i don't know i just
i i'm going to miami in like a week and
a half so be careful out there
yeah that's what i'm saying i bought a
bunch of hawaiian shirts i
bought a bunch of hawaiian shirts send
out the vibe
for what i'm gonna stand by the bar and
put out the five
i bought a bunch of tommy bahama [__]
i'm a buttoning four buttons bro what
the hell are you on
yo you have the gold chain bro yeah yeah
see it was already packed
it's already packed yeah you're rumbled
dude
i'm going away i [__] love your ass
man i noticed we met today but
good [__] i i i appreciate you coming
through
for sure i love it man it's like uh
it's been a while since i met somebody
that does a still funk
well no i know a lot of homies that do
it i'm saying it's like
people that openly talk about [__] and
still
you know do what they you're not selling
all your stuff
no i don't know what i'm saying i don't
know any of it i know i have a whole lot
of homies that live outside
because we started doing lines and then
they're like oh
klonopins like clown i don't call out
the pills all right i'll try oxygen like
it didn't do anything to me
i'm like this is nasty and then they
kept with it they kept with it they
started doing [__]
heroin oh bro but i got homies that live
outside but then they start
heroin like but now you do meth and
crying
because merced where i'm from is meth
ridden cranky everywhere yep yeah so
like
100 people i had 10 best friends four of
them are [__] up two of them are dead
and
three live outside and i got like two or
three good homies that like
are human still like a normal people so
when i see drugs i'm like [__]
i can't i can't do it that's the only
reason why because i've seen so many
people
[__] but we all started together and i
just of course
we all started doing i've had those
nights
like i'm not sure if that's my teeth or
it's my jaw locking but i'm [__] on
one like
yeah i loved that [__] it sounds
disgusting
and it is disgusting it is it is awesome
if you could see yourself
but oh yeah is that what it looked like
on the ground looking for rocks right
now
you look stupid as hell you look at
yourself you'd be like wow
damn bro i'm a dummy yep and i i stopped
doing drugs before i started making
money thank god
because that's why i'm happy for it i
don't know
dude i'm just
what hey i consume a lot of things
that's fine bro i mean drugs are fun bro
it depends
the thing is i i feel you know i mean i
i don't do a lot of things at once but
like psychedelics are my thing
mushrooms you know uh no acid oh i still
haven't tried acid
mushrooms a lot i haven't done it you
want to know why
my aunt pepper you have not tried
ever in your life lsd one time not once
why my aunt pepper and i know this is
everybody's
like whoa that's just a crazy
coincidence
my aunt pepper before i ever started
doing drugs she was in high school
okay and her friend jessica they were
best friends that's when the hippie [__]
started coming back in 99 woodstock came
back and they were okay
my aunt was always dressed like yes oh
[__] his free spirit and [__]
they were dropping acid all the time and
i knew they did drugs
but they're in high school right yeah
yeah and then i think it was right out
of high school
jessica schizophrenic completely she
went quick i saw it i saw it happening
that's not happening
i was just gonna go buy it i was just
gonna fly by it
oh she [__] went full schizophrenic
bro
after taking uh uh after one acid trip
really because they used to do it every
weekend and then
my aunt said they took it the next
morning she woke up she was a little off
and then she's been full on
schizophrenic has to live with like uh
somebody helping or type [__] right okay
and my aunt always told us don't do
[__] acid
and that scared me to death as a kid so
that's why i never did acid even when
my homies i know that it's the cleanest
ass that i've ever had what the [__] you
talking about take a [__] tap
because my homies love that they yeah i
have homies that make like dmt pens and
[__] and they
they love tripping they i have a lot of
my friends just do cool drugs and i
[__]
love that i just don't have the time
absolutely because i need to i want to
try acid i'm just afraid that it might
[__] my brain up because it's man-made
yeah in a way because i smoke weed eat
mushrooms
you know what i'm saying all i'm gonna
say it's just
it makes me a little nervous that's all
it makes everyone nervous i feel like
like when you think of what it is like
it's
it's kind of scary you know like you
imagine
i i feel like what what people's
perception of what acid is really like
is more like if you've never done it
it's more comparable to like dmt
than what assets really like it doesn't
change anything you really see
it's not like you see something that
isn't there it just you know
things that are already there they
change colors you know they look a
little
you know uh imagine like this whole wall
is just moving right it's like sounds
like mushrooms to me
oh there's mushrooms that's what i take
a lot though at once mushrooms
i don't know i've only done once so oh
[__]
that's why you didn't go pass it
mushrooms i [__] but everybody tells
me acids better it's more controllable
it's cleaner you don't feel like [__]
i love and everyone tells me that they
tell me all the positives i'm like
dude i'm scared it's crazy because all
my high school friends love streams i
would trip
like on my own all the time all the time
like i only have like two or three
friends who like to ask him so like oh
so you oh
so you're the kid doing drugs by
yourself maybe like yeah i i oh oh
great bro see it's rare you get to find
people man that
that i can relate to because [__] yeah i
like tripping by myself it's funny yes
yes yes i like spending time by my own
doing whatever the hell i want you know
doing some dumb
[__] i was uh i was talking to one of my
buddies the other day and i was like bro
we should go on amazon and buy spear
guns and like
go kayaking and like you know
like speak did you do it we haven't done
it yet but we're preparing
yo i almost got a crossbow when i was
like nine dude
amazon and buy a [__] spear gun just
to your house
that's dangerous like i don't know why
that's
like a thing like why is that a feature
like that's
dangerous they should really reach it's
like a hundred dollars
everybody's just like it's not like i'm
spending some a certain amount of money
it's like
it's like very reasonable and you get to
shoot the [__] out of a fish
that's scary that's awesome i mean it's
an awesome tool yeah
yeah that's scary but like that's
[__] great like
imagine if a home intruder comes in oh
yeah you have a
spear do you really want it like you
don't need a real gun
that's scarier than a real gun to me yes
i swear to god beard in the shoulder all
the way to the wall
yeah [__] that like that's awful dude
you're gonna you're gonna be in such
pain for such a long time crossbows too
man those are scary that'll scare
anybody the [__] out
oh a set of crossbows and more arrow
marty just
oh you out of here i'm out of here if i
see crossbows pointing at me i'm [__]
out of there bro
imagine a crossbow to the cheek dude
with the wood wait all right which way
through did you go like like
i would say like this okay so kind of
like a
straight back no straight back through
okay with the harpoon though then
they're dragging
i like that you asked that but what what
angle through that that's like a fake
oh that's [__] you get reeled in with
that stevo remember stevo's [__]
dude i've watched i've watched quite a
few stevo did you see the
the remember the fish hook and i think
of jack has three yes
remember the fish hook that was sad bro
that was sad
he's a baller for doing that i can't
hurt myself like that i can chuckle at
you getting hit in the balls when you
start
putting [__] through your cheeks but
it's not even though the worst thing for
me was
jumping in with a shark yeah that made
my skin cropper i
hate the open water is it a tragedy if
he then gets eaten like how are you
supposed
yeah of course yeah
any human getting hurt is bad of course
but like
most people trolls are gonna go i mean
he was in the ocean asking for
dude i get it but stevo you don't want
to get hurt i watched this video the
other day of bambarjara
like he wrote his own language while he
was a song
i saw it so we talked about we wanted to
bam on here
right okay and we wanted on here but
then i saw like he was going through a
rough time time and i don't really want
to like
yeah i feel that put him on a spotlight
and have him just like i agree
i'll [__] up like regret talking about
what he talked
so i started seeing him get a little
better and i noticed him he's like
i like the life coming back did you ever
[__] with cky and [__]
no no personally okay so cky is pre
jackass
okay and it's bam um
reikion okay brian d camillo
okay ryan dunn okay and there's a couple
more people and it was their
uh jackass they they're the ones that
started [__] before youtube it was like
uh trash can off the [__] roof all
right let's get it
and they would just do a bunch of crazy
[__] but the band
cky is from like that
off shoot i've it's so good they're like
to 19. like it's the golden years of
them and that's how i always like
like i talked about it before when you
see someone all [__] strung out you
think of like when you met him and you
get all
sad and like [__] look at this full now
[__] it so now that i see him like
he was [__] up bro he's been [__] up
for a while it's like dude
where come on we need bam back bro
they're getting older dude they're in
their 40s about to be 50 like we need
you guys back before we get too old to
[__]
do skateboard he's a pro skater like he
was the [__] fool
when i was a kid bro ck why before
jackass and
oh come on man you got to watch it bro
ck you're all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
text you all this [__]
was great if everybody out there go
watch [__] cky
[Music]
but yeah dude uh cky and stevo back to
what we're talking about
i didn't jump in the room in the [__]
ocean with a shark i can't no
that fool's crazy as hell hello how
[__] up
remember the alligator [__] they did
when they put the meat in their pants
and crawled over the alligator pit
bro what's going on why do you guys do
[__] like that like
like how do you [__] how do you do
that [__] bro that's insanity to me
he said you should just do lines get
hyped up and [__] do [__] i mean
i do lines but there's nothing in the
sharks no
dude i'm not getting into the show i do
lines but i'm not [__] with sharks
that's how exactly i look i don't know
dude
a few years ago dude i went through like
i remember i
i found uh one of the best people that i
ever met
a supplier for this kind of stuff and uh
as a joke obviously you know he
he uh you know i hit up my friend and uh
we're gonna my friend kyle and my other
friend um
her name's danielle and we're all in my
car and we're sitting there and there
was this old
cadillac deville that i bought i bought
it for like
three thousand dollars what year 94
my it had 96. it was a red red
listen water came out of the passenger
side when you accelerated too
hard it poured out inside of the car
what do you mean oh can you put your mic
down like point it down a little bit
point it like like
water came down like actually all the
way into the passenger seat
was it raining no just whenever i would
drive
anywhere why i broke
it was a cheat card at first
i was mad at first i was mad i was like
this is shitty i'm so mad but then i was
like wait this is kind of funny
it's funny it's it like this is pretty
lit so i kept the car
and my friend kyle he rode the car so
much he would just keep his feet up he'd
just like put his feet up on the dad how
much
water yeah bro no you have no
[__] idea it literally it would just
pour
in it would be so engine or something i
don't know
man i never got checked out i didn't
give a [__] i just drove it
i just found it i don't i have no idea
dude
i just [__] drove it until the wheels
fell off
dude yo yo every time i step on the gas
it floods
that's the funniest [__] i've ever heard
that's the best
junkered lemon story i've ever it was
but it was fast as [__]
dude the old devilles
were like super quick dude
they were decent yeah dude the old
impala is too like 95 in the palace yeah
and the caprices
i love those farther you look at cops
sometimes but
i love that yes yes i agree
so um so we get back on topic a little
bit
we were talking about oh and then we
said i want to take a bite of cocaine
bricks
oh that's we started talking about
cocaine when's the first time you ever
started [__] with it
and then i said no not [__] with it when
the first time you had a homie yo that
was a 45 minute rant i feel
good [__] i don't care that's fine all
right that's fine nice
so when's the first time you started
[__] with
drugs did somebody get you it did you
decide were you at a party
that's how i feel worse than about a
bunch of friends and you said [__] it
i'll try it gotta define drugs
no no i'm talking about cocaine cocaine
just okay just just
it was an accident my friend i went to
my friend's house
he uh his older brother lived in the
same house as him
and they stored drugs in the same way
and like notebook paper
they we used to crush up zanz and snort
him because you're stupid
yeah and like i don't know what to do
[__] idiot thing to do
yeah so he pulls out the wrong notebook
paper that is coconut instead of the
sandy thought he crushed on it
because this ants are white right
surprised like
we we do this [__] and leave his house
and like two minutes later i call him
and i'm like bro
what's this feeling this isn't xanax
like
i'm not saying what is the [__] we asked
so this girl named michaela she was
driving us god bless your soul such a
nice girl
she's so straight edge like went to art
school all that kind of stuff
god bless her right she
uh she drove us and we asked her to pull
over so we could race her car like on
foot
we were like i was like because you just
did coke for the year
yeah we were like did you pull over
so like like
i was so young i was like maybe 17
16. oh okay okay i mean i wasn't super
duper young but still i was just
i was it was like i wasn't ready at all
and we did a lot of it like the lines
were fat because we thought it was xanax
we were like oh
that's quite a bit of it let's just do
[__] all of it
you know all of it so i was sent
out of my mind i mean it wasn't the best
stuff i've ever done but
it was good enough to get me stupid my
first time to the point where like
i barely functioned oh i like we got
back uh
she dropped us off at the corner of my
friend's house me and my friend we just
like we were so excited that we just
walked around the whole neighborhood
we just like took a stroll around the
whole neighborhood like three times he
just
walked around [__] mean mugging at
like you know
12 a.m dude just strolling around
enjoying ourselves we i eventually went
back home after i came down
i was like dude that was the best
feeling ever
like that was great but i didn't do it
again for a while because obviously like
i didn't know anyone would give it to me
at that point
his older brother didn't want to sell it
to us because i mean his just got joint
you know
he didn't want to talk about that so
i didn't do it again until i mean i i
started hanging out with some other
friends after i dropped out of high
school
oh she never finished high school uh i
no i got my ged
oh that's that's fine yeah it's safe
that's the same [__]
same [__] what age did you stop going to
school um
senior year beginning of it and your mom
didn't kick you out for that [__] but
you can't shout out for do you want so
the reason i already was kicked out at
that point
i moved back in with my mom and i got
kicked out
i've been kicked out numerous occasions
me and my mom are good now
because i live on my own now so she
doesn't care anymore
but um yeah that was uh
so you dropped out of high school senior
year what'd you do for that extra time
dude just drugs
all i did was just yeah smoke weed and
take acid because i
uh i eventually got put on appropriation
because i was awaiting uh
like a sentencing for a case where i
stole a bunch of [__] from walmart
got caught i took uh you know those
plastic tote bins
so i opened one and filled it up with
games in the clearance band that didn't
have alarms on them and then i closed it
what substance were you on for i was
drunk
oh that would make people do some stupid
[__] gotcha yeah so you're
openly going around filling it up with
games i did this three or four times
before though and got away with it
i go sell them at gamestop i go sell
them at like two or three different game
stops and make like 300 bucks and go buy
like a zip or two
it was great dude bro you're on some
[__] from merced
kids in another country i mean other
countries fools in other states are
doing the same [__]
it works so well dude like i don't know
it was just the perfect
i know i have i can't believe fools do
this in other places
i i've seen so many people do the [__]
like this and i'm like yo you just
walked and stole that [__] dude i don't
know
most my like none of my friends who
really ever do it with me but back in
high school i'd always steal liquor
me and my friends oh my friends just do
that all the time but the worst is when
you have that plastic top
and you got a [__] solid [__] the
[__] off you know how many nights i
would give him 10 bucks because
i don't steal full i'll give you 10
bucks like i put in on alcohol yep and
you guys spend it
because my mom told me to go to hell i
was a kid if you stole so i never stole
before
and it's just stuck with me you've never
stolen i don't [__] steal [__] i
still change from my grandmother
though from companies i don't steal from
people i don't like
like that [__] you
dude you're you got money like your
company dude like if it's like a [__]
walgreens dude get [__]
get [__] he says you're out of luck
dude
you're [__] out of luck what was that i
remember those days
hey i mean not anymore but like back in
the day like in high school it is what
it is did i have friends who like
we still have like five hundred dollars
on us because we'd be selling [__]
ass and weed and [__] but like we still
just go
steal one dollar arizona just for the
[__] of it you know
like just because i mean it's it's the
concept damn bro you sound just like
it's crazy man it's it's it's weird to
hear people
be and it's so relatable because i mean
i wasn't stealing but my homies are
doing this [__] every [__] day and
stand by raley's like
oh and i saw him get chased out a few
times but they have the bottle of taka
they have the bottle to rock they have
that's the rock as long as you have
this model you're good you're running
with the bottle and i just run to ryan's
house
i didn't steal the [__] but i remember
thinking
dude other people do [__] like this yes
yes yes they do i always thought like
are we yes they do bro are we just
hooligans out here
oh i remember the first time we drank
giggers on the corner [__] cordova
right there merced i drank it go black
licorice what the [__]
oh wait it's bomb at first
because i hated it at first it was black
you got to let it sit for a minute
it's exquisite it's bomb as [__] but
when i used to chug like the little the
you know the little not the not the big
bottle like the small what did you say
they sell like 10
the square bottles that's a fifth they
have handles
in my seat and they're fifths and then
they have these little ones
oh my god i was drinking fish i didn't
know that was a fifth
seven how are you straight yeah yeah
yeah yeah damn so anyway i like the way
that felt so i used to chug as much as i
possibly could and drink
bro so you should drink the same as me
yeah yeah that's why i was talking about
that drink on stream
you're saying like that's great that's
what you used to do yeah yeah but i'm
just saying like we just do it
run through [__] yes and [__] yeah
just trying to like
dodge [__] i [__] hate getting chased
by cops bro i really
it's the even though i'm not gonna get
that much trouble it's the fear of like
don't be the one homie that gets caught
see i'll be the one guy i've i've been
in a position where like
i have no visible tattoos i feel like i
speak well enough where like i can kind
of get out of situations
even if like i try getting caught you're
done
maybe maybe it's different where you
live though i'm different it kind of
depends where you are and i obviously i
don't go on highways that's my policy
state troopers don't give a [__]
they don't care who you are where you're
from what what you got
they'll [__] you dude but like as long
as you're not
at least in my state if you're not on a
highway you're good to go
i mean around here i didn't i don't
think i saw a single cop on the highway
honestly man how are you gonna pull
someone over on the freeway when there's
[__]
thousands of cars i don't i don't little
speed
but when there's never been
bro i mean it's [__] fun sometimes no
i don't advocate speeding
i'm only going like 70.
yeah 70 is a good speed but uh
yeah there's places you can speed out
here so you don't go on freeways or
highways back home
um but yeah like i said it's weird and
i'm not weird it's
weirdly awesome to hear somebody doing
the same [__] because when i
like i said when i was a kid i just who
else is doing stupid
[__] like this i was just a dumbass
yeah i feel like i grew up in a way
where i was dumb but i was stubborn
you know and as i've gotten older and
like kind of modified my use
when i was young i feel like i genuinely
was more like addicted to
stuff in like a negative way but now
it's it's
more of like uh you know i smoke my weed
i do my work
and then i have my fun right sometimes i
i do a little bit of coke to work but i
feel like that's important
i have friends that do lines every eight
seconds and they're terrible business
it's terrible winners doing good [__]
but
you can it is it is i know what happened
what happened to me the reason i stopped
doing [__] coke the last time
i got a crazy sinus infection before my
equilibrium was off after a night of
just doing [__] rails
i was with rosie i was still doing
[__] coke when we first met
and i was doing rails rails and then
when i was done after like four
i went why do i feel kind of tired what
is this fool
that's the last time i saw that homie
actually but
the next morning i woke up like i feel
weird and then
for two weeks i couldn't even like stand
up without feeling dizzy and
like spinning and [__] and i had to work
and that's how the first time i ever
drank lean
by accident i don't [__] with leaning i
don't like leaving you either i don't
[__] with
the only time ever is when i was so
[__] up my dad's older i have some
medicine stuff
just drink the rest of the bottle and so
i chucked this bottle this like dark
bottle but it had his prescription on it
so if it was like right here so i chug
the rest
and i just started [__] puking up
black slime
and my nose is bleeding i was spinning
from the science infection
and i look and says prometheus even
codeine i'm like dad what the [__] is
wrong with you
then again i should have read it but i'm
sitting here spinning with a science
infection
that's why i stopped doing coke man that
and uh chris farley
he was so funny and fat and it's like
he's gone i don't want to do drugs
that's why i stopped doing drugs because
i'm like yo
i can't i can't just that's why for me
because it just takes one [__]
[__] to sell me something stupid
yeah
even though i know i could see the
breaking blah blah what if my heart
decides to go
not today i would i would uh
i just had a buddy of mine who uh i
trusted i would do that internet stuff
you know to get to get his supply you
know the db kind of stuff yeah
like still something yeah yeah i've
never been honest i heard about it um
yeah he i i left that to him for the
most part i've done it
here and there i've made videos about it
but you know it's not something i really
like to do anymore because i feel like
it's like
obviously so many sites have already
been compensated by like the fbi itself
they already know about it it's not
worth the risk anymore
like back in the day it was kind of a
cool thing you know if you had a homie
that did
it that you trusted you get stuff for
cheap like
like dirt cheap like i remember my
friend used to get
he used to buy like like xanax
and he'd pay like a dollar 80 a pill
damn
for like three milligrams like presses
not just not scripts you can't buy
[__] scripts dudes
script listings literally like don't
exist what is that
i don't feel like prescriptions no i get
it you talk about like full bottles and
[__]
no i'm talking like all right so
sometimes people will
they'll press like the powder they'll
buy
uh and make the pill themselves right
sounds
scary as [__] but some people are really
trustworthy with it and good at it and
they actually make good pills
and some people they'll like
hypothetically sell
a prescription right like like they'll
get a prescription this helps
they'll be real and they'll sell it for
like a super duper tax per pill
like like probably i don't know like 10
bucks a pill honestly because they're
super
like they're rare no one has that [__]
but i mean my friend used to pay like a
dollar 80 for some presses that were
really nice honestly they just sell
shitload of those and those
those are the way to go for him i never
liked xanax that much personally
i i i don't think i've ever even [__]
with it man i can't even remember it's
not
that fun i just don't like pills but
i've seen so many my homies just get
[__]
yeah i don't i don't really think i like
many pills either i like
i like psychedelics that aren't pills i
like stimulants you know i like my weed
the most
obviously i mean i feel like there's my
core three my
my trifecta
it's fine and jager yeah yeah yeah yeah
yours needs to squeeze in there so you
don't [__] with hennessy at all do you
[__] tequila
it depends on the day okay i see i i'm a
mixed drink kind of guy honestly
i used to be man i used to be i don't i
i like uh
there's no liquor that i'll just go get
just drink straight
you know either i prefer that i mean
what do you chase like what what kind of
tequila like water i just rejected
realized
really yeah so you just take a shot
tequila and then you just like take a
sip of water
because i used to make mixed drinks only
and i always notice i wake up and feel
like
my skin's tired i'm bloated i feel kind
of syrupy
and [__] it's the sugar and all the
liquor when i start i went
one day i'm gonna be like a [__]
lawyer and just chase with like ice
water
and i started just stopping through it
for two or three weeks
and now i it's all i drink with liquor
because
bro you're just getting hydrated the
whole time and you're getting [__] up
and i've never felt shitty the next day
no matter what i'm drinking when i'm
drinking with water
i feel awesome like i feel [__]
awesome that's
honestly when i get shit-faced that's
brilliant and it lasts longer i feel
like
i'd be drinking [__] fifth and a half
off that [__] i was just waiting on
bringing the bottle over here from
though
i got some tequila over there so we can
take some shots in a little bit
yeah let's [__] take a shot
all right beep here we go
whoa what kind of liquor is that they
ran out of the [__] uh
you ever see the big ceramic bottle blue
in the white ceramic bottle
and it has a bell on the top no actually
it's a [__] bomb but it's so
expensive and everyone loves it so it's
always sold out i've never seen it
bomb but it's like 180 a bottle oh geez
which is cool like
someone's drinking often so yeah yeah
you gotta you gotta go hard when you
drink because i just fell in love with
that i wish it was 30 bucks
i just like that tequila cause my homie
got me on it i'm like yo how much is it
oh [__] you
of course it is [__] you just got me
onto some [__]
so this is the only alternative they had
but it's really good
one little one or a full shot ah give me
a decent shot
all right there we go oh boy
why do you still want one yeah
you use water as a chaser yeah
i'm telling you it takes it away or you
know what you should try i'm sipping a
little bit of apple juice
it just takes the way of any liquor my
homie showed me that one night at the
studio thing
and uh apple juice after some hennessy
takes away
every [__] taste of hennessy out oh
boy i love hennessy but sometimes man
it [__] you up uh marty
good lord marty come on in
chase cheers oh we're not done guys
there's still more to talk about
oh that is rough
it's warm room temp i need a fridge
you totally do need a fridge that room
temp that room just hit me hard
that was a shot right there holy [__]
all right wow let's move on
okay let's move on something i've never
tried
okay i've seen you make some videos on
it and i know it's here about it
i think it's sound all right let me see
if you can guess it
but just the way i've heard about it
okay
it sounds [__] awesome it sounds like
you're
completely sedated while being awake
ketamine thank you
okay you're good i'm i really
i'm i like the thought of it
i'm nervous to try it um anything that
[__] with your heart i'm nervous to try
all right jokingly
i did some three weeks ago okay now you
can say it
you can do it's legal in some places
here i think right
yeah people get induced yeah here in in
california really
all right yeah i got some ketamine
therapy very recently
on a daily basis extreme ketamine
therapy
and i i i got on stream really [__] up
and just started i played balloons tower
defense
game oh dude my childhood do you know
what balloons is
no i don't play games bro
i'm the wrong one to look at i have no
clue he has no
i'm sad you said it's your childhood
because i feel like
it's not my whole child i mean my
childhood was really like runescape and
[__]
i don't even know what [__] that is man
listen we're like mario we're we're
okay no timeout no
[__] yeah i don't play uh rpg games okay
i don't play computer games ever
you like fighting games i like fighting
games i play gta heavy
no not even that i'll play
[Music]
the second i started doing this [__] for
the past 10 years nine years i have not
played games
i played madden i couldn't imagine that
that's it i literally i'm like so
addicted to playing games
make that [__] and you do you have made
it your job so that's fine
i literally i'm like so like i can't
stop playing video games dude
i don't know if i'll ever quite stop
doing it you don't have to
i but the thing is like like i get on
world of warcraft
i just go crazy all day i never played
it now
my god he's like looking at me
you should be so grateful honestly you
can see life
dude you get sucked in my homie ratchet
man plays a magic hello
i don't know it's like a card game yeah
no i know i i i've never personally
played it but like i see it i know
people that play it i know about that
see i'm not in that world of games at
all my my cousin my little cousin
memphis is six [__] seven my little
cousin
he's uh a gamer that's what he does he's
on all [__] day he's
beating the [__] out of people in doom i
just watch him play all the new dooms
and just watch it and watch the stories
like i'm with that that new [__] is
badass but i got my ass whooped i played
doom i got [__] killed in one round
i'm done
[__] that game yeah i'm not i'm not
i the last like complicated game i
played was like
[__] dude only i don't even five
five nah i don't even i don't even know
bro i don't play game i only own two
games
oh dude you live stream every time you
play it goes hand in hand
not every time no i mean i live stream
like i try to go for like
four or five days a week it's
interesting to me i've worked with a lot
of different types of entertainers and
stuff
i don't think we've we've never as a
podcast experienced a fan base like the
people wanted you on here
like for sure i don't know why because
like as soon as you made the podcast
people just so aggressive they came to
me too
like it's not just you like oh i know
they came to people
and we're just just bow bow just going
crazy in my you know why because you
look it man
i want to say this right now for
everyone out there they always like
leave a suggestion leave a suggestion
there's a shitload of youtubers that
don't do weed [__] there's a [__] little
youtubers that do do we [__] there's no
way in [__] hell i'm interviewing
everybody
the reason i wanted you here so [__]
bad because i know people can suggest
you all day and if i
i can be like no but the reason i do
because you're a storyteller
before anything i feel that's how i
take this yeah absolutely it's i [__]
with it it's in like
it's in my realm and it's not
dog [__] you can hold a conversation
like you said you just [__] sell [__]
you know exactly what you're saying yeah
you can hold a conversation i'm not
sitting here going
so what did you like i hate that [__]
yeah so i mean
some people just aren't good on camera
maybe they're not seasoned for but
you know how to talk you know what
you're doing that's why i feel
the they know your life though is
because they're sitting with you all day
it's your life bro you talking about
your [__] life i don't know
i guess it's just the fact that like you
know when you have like
uh the amount of people like when i
streamed on youtube i had like you know
3 000 people watching me at a time like
you know that that's my peak viewership
i don't average like you know 1500 2 000
but like even at that point uh now i
stream on twitch more and i still get
like
you know four or five hundred on there
and i mean you
i guess you just kind of get used to
like answering people's just like
on the spot like pow pow bow kind of
questions you know are you a fan
of anybody else in this realm that you
watch frequently
probably not because you're doing stuff
right so you don't know that perspective
not really no all right so you don't
know the perspective so imagine
you watch everyone that does [__]
frequently that does weed stuff
they're going to know your life because
you're one show yeah and the next day
you're there's a different show maybe
it's our show and there's eric's show
and then
there's other people right so from me
you have to take yourself out of its you
and i go that's how i plan every video i
take myself out of the equation like if
i wanted to watch something what would i
want to see
yeah you know and i tell marty hey write
this part when do the time stamps what
about like
this because i know if i'm a fan at home
go oh [__]
so when you're telling your stories
people that resonates and it stays why
do you think there's views on it
it's not because the gameplay bro i mean
it is it is it is it's entertaining to
watch but it's not like
he's my favorite call of duty yeah yeah
like i i try to pick
i play brand-new mass games nowadays i
play mini but that's what i'm saying you
could play any game
i've put runescape gameplay on there
dude like just random game whatever i'm
playing at the time i'll put on there
that's
the point the the thing is i i feel like
i create content that other people
on the platform are like too afraid to
create
my opinion i don't want to say afraid
but
more so hesitant like people aren't
willing to talk about their experiences
so
openly you know people are like
i really did like i i kind of all in my
whole future on like content creation
i was like you know if i can't do this
for a living
[__] it you know i dropped out of high
school i focused on just bettering my
videos you know starting a live stream
doing all that stuff
and you know i i feel like it's gotten
to the point where i've
i've kind of separated myself from
other other creators in the sense that i
i talk about things that other people
just won't talk about on the internet
you know other people are too hesitant
they aren't willing to
i'll openly talk about and say you know
like
i i feel like that makes substance users
feel more accepted with my content
that's what i said when you [__]
start talking about you're like oh i
love your ass like
it's somebody else talking about [__]
that i see and people think like you're
[__] like well you never did [__]
drugs
yeah that's the people who come to my
comments all the time and they accuse me
of lying but
it's it's real everyday the thing is my
my
point is not to prove to someone that i
did something it's not to prove a point
that's never my objective with creating
a video or creating a stream or doing
whatever
i do i'm not on the internet to like
flex and be like oh look
i did coke i'm so cool you know oh look
i smoked this much weed i don't give a
[__]
dude i'll smoke as much as i want do
whatever i want every day like
who i don't need to post all that [__]
but the thing is
i share it because i feel that it's
really interesting to people who don't
do that
it's really interesting people who
haven't done that you know
like there's so there's such a broad
range of people that that
watch my content i get so many so many
messages
and comments and and dms from people
that are from so many different places
and
do so many different things you know i
try to keep up with all of them you know
but like
it's just cool to see like it brings
together like
i feel like everyone no matter how they
are has a certain side of them that's
interested in that kind of stuff
you know and there's not a lot of
content that you can find that's like
that
you know if you google like what is it
like to do
x drug what do you know what does it
feel like to do this substance
it's hard to find information that's
valid on that that's in video format
for sure there's like maybe five people
on the planet talking about yeah
exactly openly with followings and most
people they focus on
just totally educational fairly you know
that's that's cool but i don't watch
that [__]
yeah exactly i want to hear the [__]
crackhead stories
like [__] me too like dude i smoked
crack me too like it's not
fun i don't i didn't like it i cooked
taco i've never cooked it
oh we're talking about felipe felipe was
our last guest dude he was talking about
he called room service for a spoon and
baking soda
and they showed up with the security
because he's like they didn't believe
him
felipe a comedian he said used to be a
straight crack head
oh but that's funny is [__] [__]
awesome
that's whole leg to most people like oh
my god that's terrible
are you okay so he's like yo that's
[__] that's [__]
funny no it's shame she's like funny you
can do drugs it's
fine and you're making it okay to be
like
oh yeah i've done drugs before oh okay i
don't have to brag about
yeah you're just talking about your
experience like i said it's never been
like
so i [__] did 90 lines because i'm
[__] hard
it's like no i did a bunch of drugs and
it was a bad [__] idea that's how i
yeah because it's that's how i feel
absolutely doing anything beyond smoking
some weeds is just the shittiest idea
ever
it's bad you could drink too i mean you
know in moderation but i mean none of
that stuff is really worth it in the end
i've done psychedelics and it's not like
i've ever like opened my [__] third
eye or learned some crazy [__]
i just tripped balls and smoke a bunch
of weed until i fall asleep
does weed hit you when you're on
psychedelics it doesn't it hates you it
ups like it increases your does it i'm
saying to you personally
yeah i've never never just shoot this
shoot it doesn't do [__] i mean
you do shrews though right yeah i do
shrews so it's different though
with acid in particular when you smoke
weed on it
it like it makes your trip harder it
literally like sick
let's say you roll up a fat wood right
while you're tripping balls
it feels like you're boarding your
rocket ship
it feels like you're boarding a rocket
ship i like where you put that you're a
nasa employee
that's [__] my homie likes to take dabs
and do lines right after i go what's
wrong with you what's wrong with your
heart
you're like roller coaster's full that's
it you like roller coasters
i'm trying to get up and come down bro
please stop
stop what you're doing i accidentally
[__] dabs from cocaine
by accident all right ready you know i
mean obviously you know you know when
hash rosin gets
real dry and like the acid it'll turn
like flakes
yes and you know coke before obviously
when it's not ready you gotta rock you
crush it once
crush it maybe once a little rocky it's
a little rocky
wait let me get this straight though
you're you're the way you're talking
about it makes it sound like
you're making the hash rosin sound
different looking from the coke
am i correcting that no okay ready
say you get ate the hash rosin jar right
and you just what color was the hash
ration
white oh wow yeah like you know no like
you know the very
ends of the hashtag where it's like wow
where it's real real real dry you ever
had the real dry [__] that breaks
immediately and
yeah yeah yeah that you know those
crumbles that look like just [__]
parmesan yes that like but
that's that's like very rare kinds of
hash raj
i mean you get it from dispensaries in
my state but like streets oh sorry sorry
so you're from another state i'm sorry
i'm from illinois that's not a thing
that's very common in myself okay
so but like you can get like bubble hash
and other like really nice forms of hash
oh damn yeah oh yeah bro over here is
way different
way different i was i'm not a wheat snob
but there's a level where it's like you
know i won't smoke anything less than
that
right there [__] yeah so when i was
smoking i was getting this company and i
was getting a really good deal and then
i kind of found out they were
there was like second press i'm like oh
you little [__]
so you never had you ever see the
hashtag it's dry as [__] like
the yes yes so i had two three identical
jars right
yeah two or three identical jars and i
had some hash in it i was scraping one
and my homie had coat and he cleaned the
whole jar i was like what if i just
throw it in there like you know
throw the rest of it in there that way i
have to keep it in this bag i'm like go
ahead just clean it out so you don't
snort
hash full cleaned it out um
he put his coke in there it's the next
day so he has a little bit left
and all her jars are right here right i
know what jars mine's right by my rig
he's outside smoking a backwood because
i don't want to smoke balls in my
[__] house because it stinks
back then back then now i don't give a
[__] and
i'm scraping i'm like damn that [__] is
white white
yeah no that's because i'm sure that's
so rare where i
am dude that's oh yeah no there's hash
rosin out here like there's a hashtag
i don't know but like everybody works at
a smoke shop and he makes it it's like
it's like darker
it's not like that it still smokes i
mean i get stoned don't get me wrong
it's just it's not the same tear it's
not the same stuff
i mean we used to have this a couple
years ago but you guys are in a
different state man you're in the
midwest yeah yeah that's
that's the only reason why but i mean
the dispensary stuff we can get out
there it still is pretty fire
well it's when it's oxidized as i guess
when it like
whites over like yes like when butter
you leave butter out and get that white
film that's
the way that hash looks like there's
like a little white crumbles anyway it's
dry that jar has been there for a
[__] week
i have a new jar so anyway i'm like i'm
gonna get my wet hash and i'm gonna
scrape all my
you know my remnants out my old jar i
grabbed the wrong jar obviously i didn't
know
and i'm like damn that shit's white as
[__] but i'm scraping it together
and i have this [__] dab that's just
caked in what i think is hash rosin
yeah i [__] dab and as i'm dabbing
like and the second i hit it it tastes
like when i smoke crack
i could smell it in my nose and right
when i capped it i went
and i capped it once and went and
stopped
and i went you [__] and he came
in what was wrong like when i showed
that's your [__] me and my friends made
it ourselves like
based off a youtube video and google
instructions because we
really go [__] out of here so like it
was pretty [__]
but like
see we made it marty did you ever make
crack
i'm sorry i'm checking the cameras here
did i ever make crack because you're
from buffalo pool
no do you guys used to sell [__]
drugs bro no we just made a purse
i never personally made crack but i've
been there when crack was being made for
sure oh okay okay yeah see that's that's
what i was like we just used a spoon we
didn't use like a full pot we'd use like
a little spoon with like a lighter
you know a little bit of baking soda a
small amount of water
and your coke yo youtube yo youtube
we're not
we're not trying to give how to you have
it on your own platform it's not here
that's the main thing to be concerned
about i'm not encouraging it because i
only did it once and there's a reason i
only did it once what
was your experience it's the only
substance i've ever done i've ever done
once
everything else i've done more than once
what did you like what did you like
about it
there's not much i liked i think i liked
the fact that i did it just so i can say
that i did it
um because it's like it's a conversation
starter in my opinion
you ever made crack let me tell you with
that like you know like i
uh you know i uh i
i was on a i was on tinder like three
three four weeks ago right
um and i you know i was i was on the
dating apps looking around like i was
just messaging girls like
you're [__] smoke meth you know like
like whatever drug it looked like they
did i was just like yeah
i mean i i don't know
[Laughter]
i sure i have a picture of him on my
twitter brother it sure works you get
answers right
i mean she said no lol and then i
remember your master
so i mean i love you
i don't know bro you were [__] full
in the best way possible i don't know do
you haven't worked out pretty well can i
hit her up like do you smoke math
it's a conversation started
oh [__] i'm not going to say you're
wrong
it's not you're right you're not saying
dude no i had to process that sorry that
was
[__] incredible you're not wrong
you're not wrong but the fact you hit up
girls on tinder you smoke math
they're gonna hit you back yeah because
they know you're not a method you have
tinder
i don't care what's the right answer to
that yes
okay because i just want to crack so
she's wild you ever smoke meth
no oh that's gross i know it is
um i spoke math i um
i had interactions with a woman one time
who smoked
west but i can speak much further than
just i had interactions with a woman
that's
it she was terrible yes yeah
methods are nasty they are they're all
factual demons they're awful
they're awful i i prefer women that
aren't going to do all my drugs
yeah that's a good way to put it you
know like if she doesn't do coke
that's a big up you know it's way more
for me
that's true but like if she does coke
honestly it's not
it's like it's not but isn't she going
to judge you if you if she doesn't do
coke i think she's just
dude i'm like dating a girl right now
that goes to uh
she goes to school in florida she
doesn't give a dude i literally i like
do coke
like like off the front of it yeah
yeah like she doesn't care yeah it's
wonderful you know it's wonderful
it's exceptional yeah dude no it's all i
mean
it just makes me wish i could it makes
me wish it wasn't deadly a deadly drug
i agree with you that's it because it's
so funny like the thing is i can't
wait the way i look at it is i can't
kick my habit i might as well have fun
while i can
you can have fun yeah you can kick it i
know i can i know i can't if you want
but i'm 22.
who gives a [__] i know what you're
saying it's like we're going crazy
[__] it like she goes to school in miami
i'm going i bought five hawaiian shirts
you told me i know i totally i'm ready
to go
dude about five wine shirts and there's
cocaine in miami so pretty much
i'm going to have fun in miami i looked
up you know those hotels you can
those motels you can rent hourly no
you ever heard of this yeah yeah okay
all right they have these motels you can
rent hourly
and they're just like in santa cruz
there was one
i remember no you could it's like it's
like 50
an hour for this this room that just has
like a stripper pole in it
and like a giant golden bed fake gold
obviously but it's just the funniest
thing and i was like yo
we have to buy a bunch of coke and go to
this motel
this place i don't even remember what
it's called motel x or some [__] just
some
funny ass name i had no clue these
existed so i started talking to this
girl
it's hilarious dude an hourly hotel
yes bro it's like no you could just go
in there be like yo let me get three
hours whether
i'm good up to no good hotels one hour
weather
i'm i'm decent like oh my god
so that's miami yeah bro i didn't i've
never seen them anywhere else like i've
been to florida i've been to orlando and
what was that you got your rooms booked
already and [__] you're like i gotta do
it
you can't book in advance you just have
to go there oh [__] i have to i have to
wait until
then you can't you're not allowed to
book
i have to wait till i'm there just
[__] go and book it by the hour bro
yeah i'll be like oh we'll call you back
in six hours when we're ready or some
[__]
when your room's clean they aren't clean
and [__]
oh yeah two bottles of a breeze and a
wet rag
there's no shot no shower for sure same
mattress i mean same covers just flipped
over bro
i'm even touching the bed you're out of
your mind i'm just there to do
blow
[Laughter]
fifty dollar an hour just do drugs
sounds [__] great actually whatever
man
that sounds perfect yeah i mean no that
sounds like a like a plan
it's decent dude like the the thing is
dude
hotels down there during the time i'm
going or disgusting
i'm going for july 4th weekend it's
nasty
it's gross i don't want it i don't want
to talk about it it's a florida i don't
know why i brought it up
yeah it's in miami dude like right on
the beach i mean florida's cool but i
just hear like they don't give a [__]
about no
covet out there they don't give a [__]
about anything out there
they have sex hotels and cocaine they
don't care about
[__] bro
like i've never been to a place like
that like they just don't
keep [__] yeah it's like
it's like a better looking vegas
sex hotels and cocaine that's a shirt
right there
that's a [__] bumper sticker la they
have sex hotels and cocaine
i see the postcard with him on it
already right
oh bro i love it i love it so much
so like i was saying it's good to be
able to talk to somebody that's
uh like you said earlier letting people
feel like
oh i'm not a drug addict like no you're
not a drug guy before you selling your
own [__]
yeah are you selling stuff from your
family then you're okay do you have a
job
do you make money it's only wrong if
you're doing wrong you know
yeah consuming something isn't doing
wrong yeah it's true
the future is not scaring kids out of it
absolutely
the future is also not encouraging
people out of it to make money off
it it's it's helping people you know
it's getting them the help they need
it's like you know
rehab if you need it if you personally
feel ready to go go
if you get forced into it you're not
going to get sober
like the vast majority of people i know
that got forced into rehab that didn't
choose to go in on their own
did not get sober i've never heard
anybody go to rehab they just
live outside yeah that's [__]
that's i mean everyone just gets so
[__] up if you if you
don't if you get lucky enough to even be
alive
right you still go oh dear to go to jail
you know like it's [__]
it's terrible so i saw your video you
said going to rehab one going to rehab
two so you're forced to i have a series
i have a series yes about going to rehab
so we're forced obviously
yeah i was 17 so i had no choice my
parents signed me into it
was why i so i took some acid
that uh i'm pretty sure was fake i don't
really know my buddy got it off the deep
web
and like it was from like someone new
so i took like three tabs and just
started tweaking the [__] out
i went home and i smoked some weed
thinking it would calm me down
i'm pretty sure it was not lsd because i
at that point i'd already done a
shitload acid in my life
like i don't want to say it was
something else like 25i or something
but it's not lsd we don't know what the
[__] that is
i don't know what the [__] happened to
me you know i i have no clue
but um i took it and
it turned i was so dehydrated that
i started having cardiac arrest oh [__]
yeah and i called my mom and i was
speaking gibberish
i was [__] up i don't know why i
called my mom it was like midnight 1 am
calm down i was speaking gibberish right
she's like do i need to call an
ambulance i'm like oh no
please no you know like i'm [__] up
dude i can barely speak so she's like oh
i got
i was living with my dad at this point
that's why i called my mom right there
they're devotional
um so she calls an ambulance they come
to my dad's house
pick me up right take me to the hospital
and because i'm under 18
i i had like taken drugs that's why i
went to the hospital
um i was like really low and like i like
in my arm like my whole body was like
really tingly
really it was really strange i had like
a like a kind of out-of-body experience
almost in the ambulance it was it was
really strange
but um when i got to the hospital
they signed me into the psych ward which
is the only ward they can sign minors
into
you know they don't have like a drug
abuse ward or anything like that
um she sent me into the psych ward and
they recommend in the psych ward that i
go to like a
a residential rehab center so i got sent
out to rehab for like two two and a half
months
damn yeah no phone and uh
no internet okay so how they fix your
cardiac arrest
they put a bunch of like i was really
dehydrated which was the problem because
my oxygen levels were really
low so they uh they like i
i don't really remember because i had
like a super [__] autobody experience
i was like really
suited on whatever the hell i was on
right um
but like in the ambulance and i remember
i remember seeing like my view
perspective
through so many different interesting
like it almost felt like i did dmt
like i like i saw myself through a
bird's eye so i saw myself through like
a person's eyes in like the desert and i
saw myself feel like
like an animal in the woods like it was
crazy it was like a like a
video like a [__] cabela's hunting
cut scene you know
like some crazy ass [__] bro like i
don't know what the
[__] was going on dude you know
so i got to the hospital i had all these
ivs in me and they rushed me in
and they got me in the bed and i calmed
down a little bit
and like the nurse told me that i almost
had a cardiac arrest and i was like what
the [__] like
what are you talking about i thought i
was just shooting and the worst part is
they left me in the room after they
stabilized me
and like my oxygen rate my blood like
the oxygen levels in my blood
um they left me in the room with the
lights off oh alone
so i just stared at the ceiling tripping
balls on like some
weird ass research chemical that i'd
never done
just off my mind that sounds [__]
disgusting
all this sounds like the [__] devil
it was memorable
but yeah it was terrible at the same
time it was it was awful
were you terrified the next time you did
acid though i
didn't do acid for a good three years i
did acid for the first time again last
summer
actually you know you're not making me
want to do acid bro
no no no no because this is not making
me want because i got real [__] now and
when i did real [__] last time i had a
blast
uh just the most i was literally sitting
in a hotel room i watched car face
four times in a row and you spent 12
[__] hours watching scarface
basically
and just take care of it i didn't know
the whole time while i was tripping i
just did a bunch of blow in the hotel
room
and got yelled at by the bald security
man for smoking on the balcony in the
room
but he was cool about it and he like
he knocked on the door and i opened the
door he's like oh it smells like you
guys got some lemon skunk
and i was like that's not lemon or
anything i was like you're cool is it
that's not loving [__] but like you're
yeah you're cool as hell like you know
all right you know i could talk to you
so i was like oh i'm sorry man does this
smell
and he's like yeah can you just keep it
you know you go out to the car so
we just did hella blow and acid in the
room and then just went out to the car
and hot boxed my car
because that was when i bought my uh the
mercedes i was talking about earlier
uh when i was staying in that hotel for
the first time so that was a fun time
that's the last time i tripped
but i just i recently uh a friend of
mine got some [__]
so i'm excited to do some of that nice
man
yeah see like that story made me not
want to do acid
but i know my friends all do this acid
frequently so it'd be fine
i just i hear cardiac [__] arrest now
like
the thing is you just gotta test your
stuff
always the thing the key is safety you
know there's
there's test kits for every drug
nowadays there's no excuse to not
test really yeah you can literally
granted is dan i have a pair of
sweatpants uh
where i burned a hole in them because i
was streaming i was really drunk and i
tried to test some like
stuff that i was about to do and i uh i
like dropped it on my pants and sulfuric
acid so i just like burnt a hole in my
[__] pants
um weird yeah yeah it was not fun i
didn't realize until later i looked down
and i was like bro what i'm bleeding
oh [__] like that yeah bro it burnt all
the way through my pants and through my
skin
like it was bad i saw the marking it was
bad they don't expect people on drugs to
be testing the drugs they expect doctors
and [__]
yes that's what i'm saying i i you know
sulfuric acid
bro you can buy the chemicals online
yourself they just ship from europe most
of the time but like you know
it's the safest way to consume your
stuff i mean i test everything before i
consume it you know like
everything i do i always test it before
i do it should you just bypass the acid
and go away for the dmt then
see i haven't done dmt yet neither i
have a
a rule where i'm not going to do it at
least until i'm like
honestly around your age probably oh
yeah wait yeah
why i i've done a lot of other
psychedelics
but dmt i feel like is an experience
that i want to wait for because i feel
like i've conquered every other
substance
experience i've ever wanted and i don't
want to do all this stuff so early in my
life
because i don't want to feel like you
know oh i i've done all these all these
substances like
the guy dude it was fun the uber on the
way here talking to the guy about dmt
you say dude i bought some dmt today
and i was like what bro yeah i was like
what bro like let me get your [__]
number dude
like well like i might get like i might
hit you up before i go
home bro like [__] dude but yeah no
he he didn't want to give me his number
so i think he was capping he might have
been kept god she got you
he he was trying to talk cool either way
a friendly guy attempted him
um really guy i tipped him and
[Laughter]
you know [__] that if i'm gonna say that
[__] i didn't ask to buy any it's just
i'm sitting there telling him about the
times that i've done substances he's not
telling me [__]
and i'm like dude you're gonna sit there
and not tell me [__] and then say oh i
bought dmt today by the way
like he said that as we pulled up here
he didn't look like the guy that bought
dmt today when i saw you outside
that's you when i was on the phone is
that you yes
all right yeah yeah yeah yes yes i don't
know about that one
yes that's about liquor today yes
speaking of we should take another shot
[__] let's do it
all right are you good
yeah i'm sure boom
all right let's get on to this next
topic all right um
so you've never done meth so i'm going
to scratch that one off
you've done math yes talk to me about it
how often like how many times oh hell no
only like twice
okay okay one time i told him i said i'd
take take it to the grave
but joe is outside doing meth so i can
talk about it now
um so first time was an accident though
right
the first time it was an accident i'm
[__] pissed jennifer
i know it sounds like my coke experience
oh
this is worse you ready yes i am you
ready we just do cheers to this first
we've told this on the podcast before so
i'll tell you real quick
a little bit of water i'm not gonna chew
the water i'm gonna try to troop it
i like your slime yo move to l.a bro
move to l.a first time if it wasn't so
expensive i would love to i'm not i'm
not doing this [__] i need some [__]
yeah yeah it's a little i just can't do
the liquor
taste in my mouth forever it's just not
fun huh um
so i i've told the story on here before
so
i was at a party i went outside they
were smoking bowls out of a weed pipe
obviously it's weed
they're hitting it this girl jennifer's
girl ryan are hitting it real quick
right
okay [__] moonlight the trees i
remember like one of those uh
apartments that have a slate of concrete
and a fence and that's the backyard you
know like that patio backyard
apartment complex yeah right
so she hands it to me and they're like
you sure you want to hit him like
[__] i sell you weak give me the
give me the [__] weed like sure you
want to hit this so you know
i felt like smokey i was smoking so i
was too that's how i felt like give me
the [__] pipe
and as i'm about to hit it it's like are
you sure
i'm like get the [__] out of here i
start roasting the bowl
and i have weeds i'm like i'll pack you
a fat ass bowl don't even roast it and
then she goes it's a cabbie and i'm like
what the [__] does that mean so i'm
roasting roasting and roasting it and
i'm
and as i let it out no cloud comes out
for like one two and then right when i
do a
thick-ass cloud you ever seen meth smoke
ever seen people smoke
yes yeah that cloud that stays together
a little and then it kind of like saw
yeah it's like it's like a it's
literally like a nuke dropped
yes like it's it's it's thank you it's
like a mushroom cloud it's
it's like a whole entity yeah
that smoke right there no no i don't
i've never smoked math
but you know it's it's probably the most
highly requested thing behind this
podcast on my channel
i get harassed every day people are like
dude you gotta smoke some [__] mess
dude don't smoke man
no okay yeah i don't know yeah never
yo we got off topic so hard you smoked
crack
what happened that was nine [__]
minute nine
days ago bro okay you smoked crackers i
smoked crack
what didn't you like about it
the crack we smoked was just [__]
because we made it
and we didn't know what we were doing
she only lasted for like four or five
minutes
okay what'd you feel it was like
coke on speed like it was faster
like it was like it was like everything
got sped up you know like if i was on
you know the comcast dvr
crashing that speed up yeah yeah like
i i felt aggressive as hell and i
punched my [__] cabinet
but like i i took a hit we made a tin
foil bowl because we didn't have a bowl
of smoking out of it and just
hit it with it so yeah we just [__]
hit it hauled out a pen or something we
just
yeah we hit that [__] we were like dude
this is [__] crazy
and me my friend ashton who he passed
away and then my friend kyle
we smell crack in my kitchen and my mom
ended up finding the spoon
that was all burnt that we cooked
crackers with is it when you lived at
your mom's
yes of course you kicked it out with a
crack pipe no i was like 17. she had
kicked me off the crack pipe but the dui
was enough is your mom on drugs or no
she smoked weed with me one time after i
moved out she's not like andre
oh no she's sober believe it you know
what's funny
she's actually a drug counselor get like
like she
counsels out of here we have drug
problems of course
look at you look at me that's what i'm
saying look at me does she appreciate
that irony or not so much
she does she does now she doesn't know i
mean
now that now that susan wojcicki isn't
paying me my monetization every month
she's not going to appreciate it
that's the video that's on the [__]
you you sign the well no i
i give her two i give her a cut of it
every month like i like
what do you mean like i like pay her
some of the money that i make from
youtube monetization every month oh
okay okay i got you yeah i'm on like
absolute just
rebel mode right now against youtube
because it demonetized me and i'm very
upset
and i have to go find i have to go to
barnes and noble and find children's
books to read
that's a good one though that's a good
way to get back at it i mean i did it
one time before and i was really [__]
up i figure if i just get really wasted
and do it it'll be pretty fun
i have a really good book uh series idea
but i don't want to say it because
[__]
random youtubers yeah yeah never let him
do it never let him do i have a good ass
i you we talked about it
but uh yeah some book ideas would just
be
this should be fun bro yeah that's fun
yeah it's like hey you want to learn
let's learn i would write a book if i
could write but i can't write for
[__] you have somebody else write your
words
so it sounds like you when they're
reading how do you find someone for that
full [__] tweet it once you find it
dude everyone who follows me i guarantee
you
you no no no no you google it you tell
me like google it find me all the
information so
you know how are these people harassed
you to get me on here like do you think
anyone's gonna be like yeah i'm a writer
yes
all the time stephen king stephen king
no bro all the time i had some full
following me i was calling the better
business bureau and that's where target
goes
is this push trees don't was yellow push
trees i'm like yeah he goes oh
[__] he's my bitter bit better business
bureau that's crazy you would never
imagine the people that follow because
people everybody loves to be entertained
bro
that's people love to be entertained i
guarantee you if you tweet him by
somebody find all the information for me
to get a book [__] published
you have eight people dm dms what if i
tweet it right now
do it okay i want to write a book
somebody finds me in the future
he's [__] loophole with the
children's books on the youtube though
so basically if he takes all his videos
off and privates them
he can't get in trouble for those things
he's demonetized because his content
so if he does like i'm going to read two
children's books and then he has all
these views all these comments
on just him reading books he'll get
monetized again and then
they start talking about drugs because
they won't check on him again
and then i'm making a archive channel
and then a stream highlights channel
so like i could try to get monetized on
those like counteract it okay
yeah i mean if we were regular kids we
would be making [__]
so much money a month to be stupid
but we do drugs and we talk about drugs
that's what i'm saying you know like
if if i was just a completely sober kid
let's say i i
i don't know i make gaming videos
totally i never did substances the
amount of money that i've saved up right
now
dude i would have driven here in like a
[__]
i don't know uh brand new tesla or some
[__] you know some crazy [__] you know
what i'm saying
but like i spend all my money on my bad
habits on my vices
you know it's something that i don't
think will ever change about me and
that's something that
i i think i try to push in all my videos
like
it's a lifestyle that it's it's
like it's not for anyone like you know i
almost wanted to say it's not for
everyone but it's not even that it's not
really for anyone
you know yeah it's totally not it's it's
totally not
you're in a unique position though with
what you got going on i mean absolutely
but i don't i don't mean to just
an appreciative way because i would be
so grateful to be in a position where i
didn't do the substances i did and still
be a youtuber and do what i did right
well you totally can't that's not you
yeah that's what that's on me yeah but
this is like
i don't you could do that five minutes
listen i guarantee you
listen i create substance story content
yeah i don't lie to my viewers
i have to do what i have to do oh you're
trying to get more stories
yeah oh oh oh see
i've done so many drugs for so many days
i remember so much
that i take notes of my phone because my
memory is getting really bad because
some of the smart stuff i've done smart
though
that's a good thing to do but i mean you
know you could totally
you know all you could do is you're
ready if you didn't talk about drugs
you just be entertaining people with
other things right now i hope this is
the moment
you know you could talk about whatever
the [__] and people are going to listen
because you are entertaining you have a
[__] radio voice perspective
i try my hardest to understand that but
i'm probably you though
i'm telling you from another person i
appreciate that a lot
you fist bump me for that i appreciate
that you could thank you
thank you let's park these you could and
should bro
if that's what's driving you to do it
yeah not [__] that that's why i don't do
40 grand joints no more
[__] that [__] i should hurt my lungs
for months bro oh my lungs have been
taken dude
i'm not gonna lie before i came out here
i did my push-ups
the dude i i uh i have my friend so my
friend cody i'm not good at rolling
backwards
i'm very bad at it but my roommate cody
is very good at it
so i had him roll like a like a 12 gram
[__] extendo would last night
oh like another 7 gram one another like
4 gram one
so your lungs are [__] i would say my
legs are [__] nope
more so like i did like prep work you
know like i'm a chef
you know getting ready for dinner
service i did my prep work i chopped my
veggies and i came out here you know
ready to smoke now i got you well we'll
put that bone to use after this too
oh there's a bunch of [__] we could
smoke came why did you have to remind me
of that you'll be all right you ain't
driving
hell no i'm not dude you're getting an
uber driver to tease you with drugs
oh hopefully it's not the same you like
this oh no i mean i didn't buy it today
you want some [__] you what an [__]
you should have [__]
you should have left the comment teases
about drugs
i haven't reviewed him yet i have not
reviewed him yet let's have the
opportunity actually might ruin his
whole life
i could i believe a negative review but
i mean i'm here no he's a nice guy
no he got me here quick so i respect him
i'm gonna leave a good review
um so let's get on to that we haven't
done the math
uh keep it that way don't do that
absolutely please don't
so this is my question but this question
i feel like you
answered and my question was
what do you see yourself doing with your
following would you like to steer
towards i feel like
from me to you can't like if cameras
were off
having to keep doing drugs so you can
make videos about it
i don't think you have to do just for me
i know you like making that i agree with
you you can talk about anything
i like the thing is don't get me wrong i
love getting
[__] zooted no for sure i get there's
nothing i love better in life than
getting sent off my rocker
not being able to function you know it's
fun
like it's awesome yeah but i also
realized i'm coming to the point in my
life where i can't
continue to do that if i want to do
business every day
that's the only reason i stopped doing
drugs i realized like oh this isn't for
me this is not going to work
and i've seen like now like oh you can
do drugs you need a coke and [__] like
no but i have [__]
to do no
would you rather walk in your own house
[__] paid for like yo let's do lines
that's how i always considered like [__]
you can have both
but do i want both i'd rather be
absolutely business-oriented the amount
that someone like myself you know per se
would spend on substances
coco's quick man it's nasty that's like
a 600
or 700 every three four days at my peak
i was at like uh
probably two three grand a day oh you're
just
you're just doing drugs i get you yeah
yeah you're not really doing a lot of
drugs i'm not i'm not like
you just wait you define that as a small
amount
i mean kinda i guess
it's not a shitload yeah i agree with
that
but two three games a day every single
day no matter what a few years ago yes i
broke up with a
girlfriend that's bad and i just
immediately hit up the coke man and said
i'm gonna be your favorite guy for the
next few months
yeah and it turned into the next few
years so yeah two three games a day is a
lot bro
but i mean that's easy i mean for for my
brain like if i didn't have [__] but
since i
have [__] to do you have to choose like
right now you could start doing your
videos your merch line
and you can't re-up next time if you're
gonna [__] spend all your money
yes so like i said if no cameras are
type [__]
well you could really that was my
question where are you gonna steer for
it
i think you're you're thinking the
substance abuse i mean substance videos
are the things you have to do
you can still do that [__] for i don't
do drugs to talk about drugs oh no i
understand that dude i've been working
really hard behind the scenes on some
some like i mean hey some [__] that i
can't really stay on camera
and be some [__] like like with the
merch the merch is going crazy
like i've made more of merch per day
than it made off adsense revenue per day
nice few days the merch shop's going
crazy
so i've been i've been really happy with
that that's been dope to see
because you know i i feel that when i
first started getting decent checks off
of youtube and and doing what i do
i was so dumb dude i'd go buy dumb ass
[__]
i'd go to the like if i made three
thousand dollars i'd go spend two
like a dummy it's kid [__] though kid
[__] right yeah you still are a [__]
kid bro you're 22.
i mean i know you're not you're not a
child but i'm saying like yeah when you
look back you're like oh
no 100 i agree with you but i've reached
a point in my life where i'm like you
know
like this isn't gonna last forever i'm
not gonna be 60 years old doing this
you know no matter what kind of
following i have
drugs or even just the following in
general like the money
i'm telling you bro you can ready
where in life where in life have you
you'd be able to make money off your
personality at your [__] house by
posting something on youtube right
hasn't been around that long true it
just became the biggest thing ever
within [__] three years
what happens in ten what happens in
twenty those youtubers hosting
[__] like huge award shows they're
[__] youtubers
right the [__] little boys making
eight something million dollars the
[__] mr beast guy's the most famous
[__] dude
you know what's funny as hell bro i was
gonna call of duty claim with mr beast
before he's famous
he's got so all right all right all
right i don't even know if i'm allowed
to say this on here actually
if it's too risky don't say it if you
think you might regret it don't even
talk about it because we talk about that
a lot on here
okay we're not gonna do that let's get
past it you were gonna decline with him
done i was gonna claim
them okay yeah leave it at that there's
no reason to risk anything oh but um
so what i'm saying is what happens in 10
years what happens in 20 years
when these are shows these
are cartoon network series this is adult
swim this is the
why can't the thing is i don't i don't
understand why content like ours
isn't the adult swim we have more views
and [__] monetization
and and and retention than some of these
shows hear yourself right there
then you're saying why won't this last
if we're killing that and they haven't
opened their eyes yet when they do we're
never going away
like content-wise like thinking brain
wise
we can [__] out content like not
literally in in the sense of it [__] but
like
pump out content right and and
get six figure views per video there's
so many shows on television that could
dream of doing that
in their peak yeah so think about it in
10 years
when they open their eyes to is what i'm
saying like you can do this and keep it
going it doesn't have to be like oh
i have i got to get more stories for
drugs that's what it keeps coming back
to you because i don't want you to feel
like
because i'm an outside person looking at
looking at i've done i've done that [__]
i'm doing the same [__] you're doing
with youtube and doing this and doing
that
like you got to be able to parlay even
looking at
absolutely parlay push trees into the
dopestyle and
the podcast
you have a following right now with no
backing and no production quality right
no
fools hitting there doing crazy [__] so
what happens when you do it
what happens when you do and you do talk
and it's jew and it's not just game play
or if it is game play what if it just
keeps going
think about that quite a lot you know
i'm telling for me to you
as a person that watches this and sees
it
there's so much more than that it's go
so much fun when i started making videos
it was [__] little weed nugs and
making them
do movie scenes and i was like do a
video oh let's do this then we started
talking on camera now
we're doing more and now we're here like
you can make this [__]
because you're an entertaining person as
is i appreciate that yeah so
i want i don't want you like what i want
you to take away from this is
because you don't think of that as
yourself like oh i'm the [__] oh i'm
entertained yeah
i [__] captivate p you don't think
like that nobody i mean unless you're an
[__]
but from another person looking in and
having no i don't have anything to gain
like i'm telling you like
you could really turn this into
something like
talking talking about yeah i mean bro
you know it's something that's
entertainment similar to this is what
i've wanted to do
entertainment why can't you one time why
can't you you totally can i don't really
have the money
no you have a streaming setup you're
done you could just be you
why can't it just be you bill burr every
monday the monday morning what's it
called the monday show
monday morning monday morning podcast he
gets on there
[__] he screams into the microphone for
90 minutes
and it's the best [__] he does it by
himself no [__] video he's just on
the radio like
and it's amazing you got to remember how
many people watch your videos you're
like
people want to hear about drug
substances like yes
there's a there's there's a [__]
following out there for if marty sat
here right now and told us
everything years about camera working
this and this i'm alonzo of peter
mckinnon
look at that [__] yeah i mean peter
mckinnon's killing this
so you can turn this into something you
don't have to like oh you still do drugs
if you want but don't think you have
just talking about setting goals for
yourself because you don't realize that
life unfolds in like chapters
oh absolutely you know i mean i feel you
know
i only recently got to where i was
making good money off this [__]
you can keep going prior to this you
know recent point in my life
i i like my first move on my mom's house
for me like 2500 a month
that's cool but that's when you're
renting
my rant was cheap you know but the
problem is
i i like draw i feel you that's a
[__]
that's a quote of my life 2500 a month
is nothing not enough for drugs i know
that
so imagine if you didn't do drugs often
you'd be pocketing stupid [__] money
imagine if you could do this right here
and get paid
see look wonderful scrolls you can make
it happen
you can make it happen that's what i
hope you go back home and you [__]
start streaming but streaming in
long form maybe it's it's more than ju
or do what the [__] you're doing anyway
on twitch and [__]
but just do it right here bro your voice
and the way you look is contracting
it's like i mean it's like a contrast
it's contrast sorry it's kind of it's
contrasting yeah
i get that a lot you know same here bro
all the time they're like
i didn't expect you to look like that
yes
i did not especially look like that like
howard sterling all the [__] time
howard stern was like a [__] muppet
and the biggest show ever because you're
like wait i didn't think he's gonna
sound like that
and it's not even that it's you're being
so open with everything
right you're being open how many people
are open with what they do or what they
like to do
some people would admit it i admit that
i might i [__] love cultural damage
don't do it no more but i [__] love
it and i will say that because i'm not
lying i love that [__] but i can't touch
it
yeah that's just me personally if god
came down and was like bro
you're gonna live till 90 no matter what
you do do all the drugs you can like
marty yeah marty can we do a cocaine
vlog please
today i would do it because it's it's
just something that's like
it's not good for your body it's going
to hurt you why do it for me
i have hello like i said i have helmets
to do drugs still [__] it if that's what
you do
[__] do i'll chop it for you i've
dropped many lines for my friends yeah
i've chopped lines for
i'm the best i can turn a point two into
[__] dirty lines dude
it just turns into power snow [__]
fast i was sitting there in my house
today and now it's like
i just don't do it i was like man
i should like go to my friend's house
and grab some
and sneak it on the plane but i did oh
no
no no way i don't know man so i hope it
look it
so if that the reason i brought this all
up because you said well i need more
i gotta do substances to do i gotta do
what i gotta do
i just don't want you to feel like
that's you're you're that's what you got
i understand i know it's your life do
whatever you want
i am somebody else so is i
i love coke right now it's just having
to slow down like
like i'm you can't do business and
someone goes like full does coke a lot
like
this it's hard to do business like that
man
in the in any any business any scenario
clothes
anything that you're doing merch and
doing the [__] dude
doing some mobile game ads it's fine do
your [__]
i'm telling you though i tags
confessions shits are tags
good keep doing that but i'm saying you
could branch off and be getting paid
just for being yourself
just talking and you should be which you
already are
doing but you don't maybe maybe because
you're saying i can't be doing drugs
like this forever like i'm at the point
where i'm trying to say you realize
you're laying the foundation for
yourself right now it's not necessary
the thing is
yeah i'm not necessarily talking like oh
like can't you drugstore this
i'm more trying to say like um
the viewers should of you or what
like the viewers shouldn't do drugs
forever i'm not really
like like i'm not really trying to push
like oh i can't do drugs forever like
dude honestly
i know old men that do drugs as long as
my nasal cavity works
it's getting abused i get that i
understand that
that's how i felt too but i mean maybe
you'll have it later in your life that's
fine i knew it was like 23 ish when i
first started was like
i'm doing drugs you know because i saw
like
ah bro there's so much more i could do i
mean you have a platform that people
would die for
and pay for and the following people
died so don't
die for the platform i mean this is what
i'm saying
i'm very good at controlling myself for
sure
you know i mean i wouldn't say i'm not
trying to say like oh i'm an expert this
that i'm not
no and i'm not i know you're not just
sitting excuses [__] you just talk about
how you feel
i feel i feel you know um when i consume
those kind of things you know i only do
like a line or two and i'm like okay
this is enough for now
i'll chill oh i totally understand that
you know i have homies to do that [__]
all i mean it's it's normal i don't ever
bat an eye on it like they're doing live
it's like some hunter s thompson [__]
yeah well we won't say we won't say
anything but my friends that was here
that
he just had a [__] coke and mary's
like whoa oh yeah he's just gonna do
some lines right here real quick
while we were just like doing [__] and
filming like it's my homie
you just do some drugs junior follows we
talked about this
and you on instagram we talked about why
and then we said [__] give us a
check mark
give us a check mark it's so funny it's
so
wild it's random right it's so funny
though
we have a presidential direct connection
like
do you see what i'm trying to say turn
this into
something bigger you can i mean yeah
i i'm just talking about the way you are
bro the way you are the way you're just
talking i know saying it too
you're seeing it too it's like bro this
i hope this is not the last time you
come over here because this is [__]
no
and i love it no listen listen i'm
coming i'm bringing my girlfriend in
like
august bro i'm coming back perfectly a
fun time but
that's what i'm saying like four or five
days it's gonna be a good time and i
wouldn't say that if i wasn't
being serious i don't watch you talk
about random [__]
so so other people that already like
your [__] and talk about it it doesn't
have to be about drugs that's what i'm
saying
and then after drugs what else is there
on earth
everything well i literally just about
said the same thing yup
you could talk about anything bro talk
about the news talk about the biting kid
talk about whatever you want
you don't like like i said i'll leave it
at that at that point
you're more entertaining than just drugs
and drugs are entertaining
i appreciate that you do more the thing
is i don't
use drugs for content i use drugs for me
and create content oh the only reason i
brought it up because you're like i got
to do drugs still
to make more videos i'm not going to lie
that's the only reason
i mean yeah of course that's all i meant
but i mean i don't
that's not like the number one reason i
do those things right
you got yourself i don't know drugs are
funny that's like you know
um is what you're like
[__] dude he's not a rapper saying i
gotta keep shooting [__] got a
new album coming out i gotta write some
songs yeah no no that's that's
when you said it earlier that's like oh
[__] no no that's why well the only
reason i ever brought it up too honestly
but i know you're not just doing drugs
so i could talk about it you do drugs
because you take them
like i i don't think i'll ever stop
doing that uh
you know someone i know yeah
someone i know stop doing a little coke
man it's all good it's your [__] body
as long as you know what you're doing
you don't you know what you're doing 100
[Music]
so that was the question and my next
question is
what's the quality of weed in your state
i'm so glad you asked this
so there's about two good companies
it's recreational there or is it medical
both damn
really yes i didn't know that but listen
it's not it's not good so recreational
if you buy a concentrate you pay a forty
percent tax
forty that's how much it is it's like
thirty seven now
it's 35 to 40 here 35 and 40. yeah same
here wait wait
what yeah on the record but what's the
price per gram
oh eighth is like depending on what
company could be from [__] 15
to 85 dollars alien labs 85
out the door 110 for an eighth
okay wait that's not even bad yeah
there's a price here
cheapest 180 for nate
out of the dispo okay what
yeah for good weed is it good no
i wouldn't even go it's usually douchey
price per gram about 70.
can you believe that of weed
no no no uh no no no concentrate
oh oh oh yeah
some hash here's 120. but that's just
i'm not talking
about [__] flowers bro what's that
that's what i thought you said
i thought she was like what are you
talking about that's crazy
so concentrated what there's some
companies here 120.
pre-tax 120 on certain hash rosins
but no dude um that's a that's absurd
it's still two tax
that's absurd i bought 190 grams to do a
video
and it was a hundred or 200 gram i think
it was [__] ridiculous it was the
isolate oh crazy cro
literally looks like crystal meth oh
hey that got me going dude they got me
ready to hey smoke some of that
hell no oh no hell no
i have a question near death experiences
you ever have that besides having
[__] cardiac arrest on fake lsd
because that pretty much was my question
because that's crazy as [__]
what the [__] did you ever find out what
it was
no not particular but like
that that was just such a wild
experience that was my quest i have a
definition my limbs like tangled like
that bro
that's jerry's fault it was scary stuff
it was dude i like literally saw like
the light
it was crazy like it was spooky it was
just spooky
yeah i was like terrifying's a better
word it was spooky
yeah if i saw the light like yo it's a
little spooky
i saw the conscious when it happened
where you're like this is the [__]
light
i was just sitting i was like i was
freaking out and i i was seeing i was
like i just gave i just let it happen
i thought i was just tripping balls
so i was like i was like i'm not
dying you know this is a great trip
simulation of death oh i thought i was
[__] going to see
like jesus on my trip i was like this is
[__]
fire so you're laying there and you're
just like i'm with it i'm just letting
it go
yeah bro i saw myself through a bird's
eye view
over the forest bro yo
i i don't see jesus on my train this is
sick
yo i would let
[Music]
i've had trips where i'm completely gone
like on salvia
i [__] with salvia heavy that's the
worst drug on the pla
i hate i've never done salvia don't keep
it that way it's disgusting it's like
having a mushroom trip
but a bad trip all at once in 30 seconds
to a minute
and when you come back it always feels
like you pissed your pants oh god
no matter what happened where i was
always felt like i pissed my pants
i had to like check because i wasn't
like you know i'm in a room full of
people i really was that's
awful it's the worst bro
so besides that we can skip that
question any death experiences we
already
heard that [__] and that was pretty
[__] insane
so after we bleeped around that we're
already over two and a half hours man
people ask like you better go three
[__] hours you better go four hours
because
i relevant bombardier i see this as
the stories like this this is the other
storyteller like i want to see
you know if you were like what's up what
are you going to ask like i'm
from me to you like i want to hear some
[__] so that's why i asked all these
questions look at if you want to look
first first first first first i had so
many first questions
about first time doing drug [__] you see
what i'm saying
like i was just throwing them down like
i want to hear this i want to hear this
all right don't look at it don't look at
them all don't look at them all ah sorry
so
you're good you're good i didn't see
them all um so right here
my next question the midwest you're in
the midwest basically
saw the pills and that and that is the
epidemic out there correct
in the north yes and the south
is more meth really can you can you tell
your mic down a little bit
just shut down still you get right there
there we go
perfect perfect yep nice so
um in the south that's more myth yeah
but you used to live in the north
so the further south in illinois you go
if you go anywhere about 30 minutes out
of chicago to like 45
meth smokers they like to tweak
but i mean if you stay within a certain
race
in chicago it's some other stuff than
that
you know you can get some pills some
[__] like that the thing is
i mean i don't know
but nowadays all the pills are pressed
right
because i mean the reason i'm asking is
because i've seen this [__] online like
the epidemic of [__] fools back
there doing pills
bro i just see like it's a it's like
[__] meth out here as the way
pills are out there it depends on the
kind of pill like what like wait are you
talking like an opiate or yeah like
opiate okay yes when i say that that's
all i ever mean but they sell like
fake opiates that's what people are
dying yes
that's why people are dying they sell
like these fancy opiates
and people like what you can do with
these shits and
is is you can like shoot them up bro
pills
so if you if you get a spoon you put
some water in there and put like the
pill in there
you oh god you it it's like
gross yeah that's nasty i've never done
it but i've seen like a youtube video
of someone doing it they were shooting
up but we got them it was like it was
like a vice documentary
see vice gets away with anything as long
as they're dude they [__] do whatever
they get whatever they
get away they don't give a [__] they
could literally show someone just like
shooting someone in the face it doesn't
matter dude for sure
totally uncensored dude and then the
people would get away with it when an
award yeah i'm not hating on vice
president where's your connect can i get
a blue check
[__] yeah stop deleting me call me dude
[__] vice jesus christ they probably are
monetized
they probably are monetized that's what
they got straight crazy [__]
beheadings or
that guy i like that show you see the
guy who does a hell of drugs and goes
different places
oh that shit's cool i [__] with that
that's actually
badass yeah see that's something that
would kill it on youtube because that
guy's the [__]
and he dude he's got the backing advice
i found this guy who did
he does this stuff called stealth
camping on youtube
and he literally just sets up like a
tent behind home depot
he's like stealth camping behind home
depot
it's my favorite youtuber steve wallace
wait he just goes outside to be homeless
yeah sick on purpose to do what that
what does he
vlog about inside he like gets drunk and
cooks something
yo did you hear this morning and just
like he like bro it's it's the best
channel i've ever
he's a youtuber that pretends to be
homeless is what i'm hearing yeah yeah
no
i'm convinced he actually is like he
goes and he can't find home depot and
he's like yeah my wife's at home and i'm
like shut up you don't have a wife
dude like you're homeless bro no way
do you have a car maybe yeah actually
because he camped at an airport parking
lot one time he slept in his trunk
yo this man he's monetized that bad yeah
he's getting shocked what percent bro he
makes rags
gucci money bomb like
bro what's his name steve wallace
you put me on a bunch of [__]
today i like that
steve walls pretends to be homeless
youtuber i [__] with that he gets drunk
and cooks and has a tent behind a row
literally i like i'm telling you right
now
this is spectacular content
this is some of the best content on
youtube
i promise i gotta see it now it's like
those fools that make uh
like cabins out of vans and [__] you see
that dude i
honestly when i was young i wanted to do
that yeah i have a homie that's doing
that i uh
how does he like it he loves it he made
his van all sick he's been gone for like
five months
my homie scooched out [__] riding
around living good
he's a photographer so he just takes
product we've started for cannabis [__]
she just takes it around and goes to
crazy places and takes photos
and gets paid and takes more pictures
and lives
it looks like a little apartment it
looks like this
in his [__] place like it's got a bed
you know a place for your clothes and
[__] yeah bomb
but uh yeah that's what he's doing so
i i don't know about that personally but
that [__] sounds
i can't do it did you watch that [__]
marty tom green
did you know you don't know who tom
green is
no no tom green okay he's his old uh
do they used to be in movies he's a he's
older yeah he's just funny as [__] god
damn it hurts me to hear you
describe him but you're younger than us
a different generation
he's my obama's on your lips does that
mean anything to you oh hell no he's
like wait wait what he was lonely island
before lonely island was
in the eighth grade pretty much is how i
look at it
before yeah okay
yeah i'm not that old i don't know none
of that
the way you went in on top green was
like he's the old dude he was in freddy
got fingered
i was about to go i was about to sit but
you probably don't know anyway he's
[__] funny but he lives in the
[__] van
he travels the country he's famous
comedian basically and he travels the
country
but there's people that actually do that
[__] man and i don't think i could just
go willingly be homeless
i think if i had a sod
male spot a what like like
a like a spot to receive mail so i
wouldn't like you know
fall off the face of the earth yeah
exactly
and then i could you know like like
shower and then [__]
and also like get suited every day
i'm happy yeah simple yeah
i'm a simple i am a simple man dude
as long as you get [__] up damn that
you sound like me man
except i just do smile i just want a
place to live and and
smoke weed that sounds cool that's all
you know
that sounds cool that's all i've ever
wanted in my life that's all i ever
wanted my whole life to do and then i
just started
selling packs and i was like i used to
keep a qp of the best nugs for every
pound
and i would make my money back and be
able to kill you yeah but if you're
moving like three or four
i'd be having like a pound and a half to
myself and i go i'm not making any money
i'm barely paying my rent because all i
do is make money
but i'm spending it by smoking all my
weed
you know i was smoking like at least a
zip zip and a half fish a day
a fire expensive packs so eventually
you're gonna be [__]
yeah and uh all i cared about was smoke
and weed i don't give a [__]
i was doing instagram that's all i gave
a [__] about like dude packs
back in high school i always tried to
sell weed and a lot of stuff that i was
really into but i was so [__] at
it because yeah yeah yeah
yeah i would literally take it out and
go i'm not gonna make no money but i get
to smoke all this section
bro i'd always smoke a little more than
i should i just go downhill until i got
some more money and
that was me in the 11th to 12th and then
after that i was [__] killing it i
never once i started doing youtube like
and making these money i never sold me
and i was like [__] that like any
substance i was like [__] this
do them [__] it you know that's how i am
a spyway now
exactly exactly i don't know it was
it was weird i wasn't my friends the
other day and i saw them selling some
packs and looking at like
damn i just wanna sell weed so bad again
i just look it's just
fun bro it's like a how many it's like
video game points it's like yeah yo
[__] yeah yeah yeah it's just fun boom
boom
throwing money in my backpack and [__]
like ah it's like a different feeling
like when you have a duffel bag
all the [__] packs i just love it
dude
i just love going this guy attacks
and he never complains because he's
taxing the [__] out of people
you know this guy no don't say nothing i
taxed him so [__] much
hey what's up man that's i missed like
certain [__] people that were dicks
just taxing people
and then i remember hooking all my
friends up so i just as long as people
had weed man
and i made my money enough to smoke weed
i didn't care
exactly i didn't care i was never trying
to get as long as you got
high every day and pretty so i felt yeah
broke even into
yeah at least break even i break even
because i would smoke so much
you know i just smoked so much yeah i
could break even focus
same [__] dude like i i half time i
wouldn't even break you
exactly as long as i could just smoke
weed for free like [__] yeah
i bought some food today yeah nice i'll
buy another house
yeah dude um so that was pretty much it
on the [__] uh
questions i had man i think i asked oh
hold on
i got some fan questions okay before we
stop this yeah
let's get this let's get this real quick
let's run it what what's the hoot and
holler thing
that's a question coming from me okay
all right so
it's kind of a saying i just like
started saying a long time ago i mean
it's like a good video
you know like an actual the way people
actually say it
that's what he's saying there's no like
there's no i
no it's just the way you're saying it
it's a hoot it's just a hoot and a hole
it's like oh it's about to be a damn
good time yeah
it's the same thing for the midwest this
is going to be a
hollow podcast that says like saying
have a dope day it's just synonymous
good answer yeah it's it's a little it's
just saying
and every time i hear i'm like yeah good
[__] oh i can't oh we can't do that one
uh the hardest month of your life right
there
i will skip to this one ready go from
agayo from twitter
does he ever regret doing the amount of
drugs you've done
no simple answer there's literally
nothing else to say
no it was fun but then again we're not
advertising
or absolutely not just your personality
had so many negative consequences i'm
just
i don't know i'm i'm out of pocket
where do you think you'd be right now
had you never done drugs
if you're a stranger would be as happy
as i am right now
mm-hmm does that [__] i just [__]
every day
uh well you know hypothetically as a
joke
you know not literally
yeah perfect that's literally
everything like that was the perfect
last little paragraph
[__] hypothetically yeah i [__]
love your [__]
oh my god dude we've been here for a
long time it's been almost three hours
good [__]
yeah no we should stick around this has
been [__] great
i'm stoned bro yeah i'm high too i'm
[__] big that weed is so good
it is it's strong as [__] yeah oh
oh what is my homie remember i told you
gtpg
yes that's everything my homie oh my god
this is the dispensary i was telling you
about i always go my homie runs it so i
just chill
oh gee he was on the podcast he runs
this dispensary how do i consume this in
12 hours
oh cause you gotta leave this is gonna
be so lit
these stashing dash for your homies [__]
it no i'm gonna do it dude i'm gonna
[__] do it all
do it [__] yeah smoke it all we just
took that as a challenge and [__]
i'm gonna i'm gonna honestly go back to
my hotel tonight
just a lot of story [__] dude i
do you have to take it you have to take
it out right now real
no problem dudes i know you'd be here
after and you won't be able to go
dispensaries
you're so real no problem at all smoke
before we forget [__] legend bro take
that [__] we should smoke some of this
[__]
well that's all you man we got other
weed to smoke white to go
that's all we just smoked down too i saw
you and if you don't smoke at all just
be like yo twitter
i'm at the [__] airport come pick
that [__] up i'm out
he's leaving for a [__] follower or
something that's funny is he sure
i love doing that [__] bro i do on
snapchat that's pretty no that's
actually perfect if you don't smoke it
all [__] it
best leave it for somebody they'll smoke
and be hyped that you got it
i love that idea i love that yeah i
appreciate you bro this is a [__] fat
ass sack
no problem dude this is [__] funny i
don't think you're gonna be able to
smoke it off but
i'm gonna try my hardest bro
everything that is edible is down the
hatch that's easy yeah that's easy but
there's a lot of like
crazy distilling hash and this and then
i saw the picture bro
there's a lot of crazy things with it i
started kind of tweaking bro i was like
i started to tweak
i literally i i was like bro i have to
smoke all the weed i have
left bro it's like what the [__] is
going on here
you're good bro and i'll give you if you
need papers or a little bong i got oh
bombs unless you fly out of
relax with that [__] right but it's just
when you land you might have a problem
yeah yeah when you land in your home
state you might have a problem and
how because you're landing oh he's in a
[__] recreational state
then i cannot scare you i haven't no you
could take that [__] back
yeah take that [__] back look at me with
the big [__]
[__] sorry father i'm sorry fans but
if you could take that [__] back take it
with you hey please
i was saying if you can't leave it
cracking tsa agent in the head with this
bag
[__] santa claus um
oh that's right that's right before we
go where can everybody find your social
media
what are you on the most all right
youtube
just type in goblin i'm the first result
uh hopefully i'll stay there for a
little while even after i have to vault
my videos but if not my instagram
it should the gbln t-h-e-g-b-l-n
so common disability got you yeah yeah
gb
and twitter too which is just the goblin
with three hands on the end
i hate when [__] take those
dudes with my pictures
and i'm mad bro i'll do anything for my
name on something except
pay for it
[Music]
oh that's the whole business people
[__] scam of course that's why
i know i've known somebody for a while i
have a lot of friends who used to do
that [__] bro i'm not
no i'm not doing that [__] you know yeah
if you don't use it like that [__]
exactly
it's just something you care
that doesn't change anything you know
what i'm saying but when it comes to
business [__] that it helps
but if you don't use that platform like
that why the [__] would you pay for it
yes exactly
i use it literally just to post pictures
of myself and then like sponsor posts
and that's it
that's all it's for so instagram kind of
[__] itself bro it [__] yourself
when it kind of kicked it everybody went
in
i feel like could have been cooler and
the real [__] is garbage
you know that like kind of like
tick-tock oh the reels the only reason
we have to use it because they want you
to use it as a feature
so when they go like they're like their
next meeting like see we're competing
with [__] kids
[Music]
they only like promote people dancing
and like stupid [__]
the worst [__] you could see the dumbest
[__] i've ever [__] seen in my life
fake skits
i'm [__] over it dude
it's tiring bro sorry we got off topic
hard we can get anybody to get my names
so youtube goblin yeah
twitch uh gbln420
gblm420 yeah well poppy's up on the
screen because we can't leave links
i can't even links to my own [__]
because we show weed yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah so we'll pop these up on the screen
for everybody to see them um
so your youtube goblin is the only one
that you got this oh
[__] i hate that [__] i got four
underscores in my neighborhood
so i feel you no yeah i got four
underscores in my [__] name now
because people can be deleted bro i
i'm i feel like i'm on the verge of that
happening
[__] you keep going i know that's
that's what i plan to do but still it's
just a pain in the ass you know
[__] yeah you know how many new phones
i've had to get dude
annoying so many new phones do you
realize why i have an iphone se
because i keep having to get new phones
i'm not going to spend money on a new
like you know
good [__] phone when i have to buy a
new one it's so annoying i got like 50
different [__] icloud
you talking about for like uh every time
you get to leave they scrub your [__]
name your ip all this [__] i have to
get a new [__] boost
new [__] that they go crazy
they go crazy like you literally need to
have a new sim card ready at your crib
at all times
something else you have to have
something other phones always a brand
new
phone it wouldn't be nice it would be
nice if it wasn't so guys i flew i flew
here with three phones bro
oh uh that's
[__] annoying i got two and i hate
that [__] well
i got one and i hate that [__] oh it's
bad news
i flew you with three phones damn
yo marty you have anything else you
wanted to ask i think it was pretty much
everything i have
every bullet point good i've never done
that with a guest
[__] bullet point good [__] dude
that's [__] good
nice so we got all your socials we got
everything
dude thank you so much for coming out
thank you for flying i appreciate you
bro
you [__] straight flew out to
california to do this i appreciate that
i was down as [__] bro thank you i was
like yeah that sounds like a fun time
[__] yeah dude i just want to hear
another storyteller man i think
i think you're onto some [__] i think
you're on it i think i love the
following you built
it's it's genuine bro and i like it i
like seeing it
it's cool to see it and i can like
relate watch and i'm like
i appreciate you you know i mean that
feeling yeah [__] yeah good [__]
you're always hyped to see some new [__]
so good good good job
good for you man and like i said try to
turn that [__] into
more about you if just some advice from
me to you because it's entertainment
absolutely it's entertaining
just throw the camera on yourself one
day try it out promise you
i i want to i promise try it out so
um thank you so much you have a lot of
[__] to smoke i know you have to get
your [__] hotel so we're going to cut
this what are we at almost three hours
who gives it damn what time those three
hours let's do it i'm about to get
suited
[__] yeah thank you guys so much for
watching uh appreciate you so much for
coming through guys this has been the
goblin episode
the most highly requested person we have
and you guys you guys you guys asked for
it here it is thank you for coming
through thank you for [__]
entertaining the [__] out of me bro
thank you so [__] much thank you guys
so much for suggesting him so many times
i
completely agree yeah thank you for
coming through man
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast if you're driving
please be [__] safe if you're at home
chill with your homies thank you for
making us a part of your day
thank you for making us a part of your
[__] life thank you guys so much for
watching
thank you so much for coming i'm [__]
high
i think it was always took shots that's
why i feel like this
now i remember lit now i remember now
i'm
so stoked have a dope ass day guys i
completely forgot have a dope ass day
out everyone yeah good [__] dude
that was a [__] fight
[Music]
perfect